COMMITTEE ON RULES WILL COME TO
ORDER I WANT TO SAY GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE I'M GOING TO
MAKE SEVERAL ANNOUNCEMENTS
TODAY TOO AGAIN EXPLAIN THE
PROCESSES THAT WE HAVE
DEVELOPED. TO CONTINUE OUR
ESSENTIAL WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND FOR THOSE OF YOU
THAT ARE FAMILIAR WITH THIS
PROCESS WE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE WHILE I GO
THROUGH IT AGAIN FOR THOSE THAT
MIGHT BE TUNING IN FOR THE
FIRST TIME. SO I'M GOING TO
COVER SOME TECHNICAL I'D ISSUES
RELATED TO HOW THINGS WORK
TODAY IN RESPONSE TO KOBE
NINETEEN- THE EMERGENCY TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS AND
SENATE STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
WARDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING
AND WE'VE MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS ORMAL PRACTICES IN
ORDER TO ENSURE. THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO OUR
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS BY
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WHO WANT TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THERE IS A PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND AN ACCESS
CODE AND IT IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
RIGHT NOW IT IS TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER. IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE EIGHT NINE. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. TWO EIGHT SEVEN SIX
ZERO FIVE NINE IT'S ON THE
WEBSITE- WILL DISPLAY IT A FEW
MORE TIMES THROUGHOUT THE
HEARING. WHEN WE DO MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT A MODERATOR WILL
IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY WILL
OPEN YOUR LAN. AND AT THAT TIME
YOU MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ANY FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE THAT YOU ARE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND SO WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND FOLLOWING THOSE-
SIMPLE DIRECTIVES. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE ARE HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. AND SO WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND TO CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN
THIS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS IS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE
SOME LAG TIMES AND WE'VE HAD
SOME THINGS COME UP THAT WE
WORK THROUGH. I BUT HOPEFULLY
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO ADJUST TO OUR
NEW ONLINE TOOL SO PLEASE BE
PATIENT AND THEN EVERYONE-
HOPEFULLY CAN BE HEARD. ALSO I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK ON BIG HALF
OF OUR- COURT REPORTER AT ALL
SPEAKERS COLLEAGUES AND
WITNESSES ALIKE SPEAK SLOWLY
AND CLEARLY. AND BEFORE WE
BEGIN THE AGENDA TODAY WE MUST
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND AS A
REMINDER TO MY COLLEAGUES ONLY
TO TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONES.
FOR THE ROLL CALL AND EVERY
TIME THAT WE VOTE. AND SO WITH
THAT MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GROWTH
HERE GROW HERE KAMLAGER YOUR-
LONGER HERE LAYERED HERE NEAR
HERE BATES HERE BATES HERE
ATKINS HERE ATKINS HERE. THANK
YOU- IF THERE ARE NO OBJECTIONS
I'M GONNA TAKE UP FIRST ON
TODAY'S AGENDA THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR AND THAT'S TO F. THROUGH
P. BUT I'M GOING TO REMOVE
ITEMS TO OUR AYE AND WE WILL
VOTE ON THAT SEPARATELY. SO IT
WOULD BE TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR TO F. WHICH IS THE
HASTINGS COLLEGE OF LAW BOARD
OF DIRECTORS G. AND H. THE
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP CORPORATION
BOARD OF DIRECTORS I'M GONNA
SKIP I'D GO TO J. WHICH IS THE
C. T. C. THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION. AND
THEN K. THROUGH P. WHICH IS THE
WATER QUALITY CONTROL BOARD-
VARIOUS REGIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE SO THAT THAT WOULD BE A
MOTION I WOULD ENTERTAIN ALL
ITEMS F. THREE P. MINUS TWO HI
SOME OF THANK YOU- SENATOR
LAYERED- WITH THAT WILL YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THROUGH
HI. I AM WATER HI KAMLAGER I
LAYERED HI THERE I BATES HI. I
ATKINS HI ATKINS FIVE FIVE ZERO
FIVE TWO ZERO THANK YOU THAT IS
OUT- I WOULD ASK FOR A MOTION
ON GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR ITEM TWO I
AND THAT WOULD BE FOR THE
SECOND MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION. THE
REMOTE THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED OUR MAN OF SECRETARY WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GROVE.
RIGHT NOT VOTING KAMLAGER I
LONGER I LAYERED AYE AYE BATES
NUMBERING IT'S NOT VOTING
ATKINS HI I'VE BEEN FIVE THREE
TWO ZERO THANK YOU THAT IS OUT
THREE TO ZERO AND LASTLY I
WOULD TAKE A MOTION ON BILL
REFERRALS- FROM- THANK YOU
SENATOR EARLIER- YOU WERE ON
TASK TODAY MADAM SECRETARY WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GROWTH
FIVE ZERO FIVE KAMLAGER HI
LONGER I LAYERED HI THERE I
BATES HI THE FIVE ATKINS HI I
CAN FIVE FIVE ZERO FIVE TWO
ZERO THANK YOU COLLEAGUES AND
WITH THAT WE WILL NOW TURN THE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES REQUIRED
TO APPEAR AND WE WILL TAKE UP
ITEM ONE A. FIRST AND THAT IS
THE APPOINTMENT OF P. JOAQUIN
ASK OF L. AS THE CHAIR OF THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD SO. WELCOME IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT INTRODUCE
YOURSELF I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN
BEFORE THE BOARD BEFORE WE MAY
BE A LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN LAST
TIME YOU WERE HERE BUT WE WANT
TO WELCOME YOU AND OFFER YOU
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ACKNOWLEDGE
INTRODUCE ANYBODY YOU WOULD
LIKE MAKE SOME COMMENTS AND
THEN WE WILL GO RIGHT. TO
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS WELCOME.
THANK YOU CHAIR REALLY
APPRECIATE HOW THE- TO BE HERE
BEFORE YOU OF. GOOD GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON
BY STRIP BATES AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- I'VE BEEN
INCREDIBLY HONORED TO BE HERE
REAPPOINTED NOW FOR A SECOND
TERM BY THE GOVERNOR. AND JUST
REALLY THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR BEFORE
YOU I'M HERE JOINT VIRTUALLY BY
MY MOTHER AND MY FATHER AND
NORMA AND FRANK ASKED ABOUT AND
MY PARTNER RYAN STEVE ALONG
WITH OTHER FRIENDS AND
COLLEAGUES. I JUST WANT TO
THANK THEM FOR THEIR LOVE
GUIDANCE AND SUPPORT IT I CAN
TRICK MEANS A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
OUR OF MY FELLOW COLLEAGUES AT
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD AND THE REGIONAL
WATER QUALITY CONTROL BOARDS
BOTH BOARD MEMBERS BUT ALSO OUR
STAFF. BUT I'VE COME TO FIND
HERE IN MY FIRST TERM IS JUST
INCREDIBLE PASSION AND
DEDICATION AND LEADERSHIP.
AMONGST OUR STAFF AND JUST
TRULY UNFORTUNATE TO BE ABLE TO
WORK FOR AND WITH THEM ARE
THESE LAST FOUR YEARS AND I
JUST. REALLY WANT TO BE ABLE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THEIR PUBLIC
SERVICE BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
SOMETIMES GOVERNMENTS AND
GOVERNMENT AND PUBLIC SERVANTS
DON'T GET PAID KNOWLEDGE MEANT
THEY CAN PROPERLY DESERVED. AND
IN THESE TIMES WITH SO MANY
CHALLENGES FACING US IT REALLY
IS OUR GOVERNMENT. INSTITUTIONS
ARE WITH OUR SELF GOVERNANCE
HERE AS A SOCIETY THAT REALLY
COMEINTO PLAY AND ARE KEY IN
HELPING US ALL COLLECTIVELY
MAKE BETTER. DECISIONS TO THE
CHALLENGES WE FACE. THERE ARE
NO SHORTAGES OF CHALLENGE.
CERTAINLY HIGH I COME YOU NOW.
IT'S NOT LOST ON ME THAT FOUR
YEARS AGO IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WAS ONE OF OUR WETTEST YEARS ON
RECORD. AND HERE NOW- TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. FIND OURSELVES. IN
AND AN INCREDIBLY DEEP DROUGHT
WITH WILDFIRES AND THE CLIMATE
CRISIS REALLY IN ITS FULL FORCE
UPON US ALL. IF AS IF WE DIDN'T
NEED A REMINDER OF THE RECENT
IPCC REPORT AS MADE CLEAR THAT
WE REALLY AREN'T AN INFLECTION
POINT AND GENERATIONAL
OPPORTUNITY TO. ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGES THAT CLIMATE CHANGE
IS BRINGING UPON US BUT OTHER
CHALLENGES THAT ARE CERTAINLY.
PART OF THIS COLLECTIVE
RECONCILIATION BUT I TRULY FEEL
WE'RE ALL MONTHS. AND NO MORE-
AT A SPACE THAN WITH OUR WATER
SECTOR. IT'S NOT LOST ON ME
THAT THE STATE BOARD NOW IS A
FIFTY YEAR INSTITUTION AT THIS
POINT. ARE YOU LOOK AT PORTER
COLOGNE WHICH IS A MODEL FOR
THE CLEAN WATER ACT NATIONALLY.
THERE WAS A TIME WHEN WE DIDN'T
HAVE. APPROPRIATE PROTECTIONS
INTO PLACE TO PROTECT CLEAN AIR
CLEAN WATER AND HELP MANAGE
BEST OUR RESOURCES OUT INTO THE
FUTURE. IN THE FIFTY YEARS
SINCE A QUARTER COLOGNE WAS
PASSED IN THIS INSTITUTION THAT
I HAVE THE PLEASURE OF BEING
PART OF HELPING LEAD- HAS AS-
YET MADE AN IMPACT IMPROVING
WATER QUALITY. BOB BAER
BRINGING TO COMPLIANCE AT
WASTEWATER TREATMENT PLANTS AND
BEGINNING TO STAUNCH THE
CHALLENGES THAT. WERE PLAGUING
OUR COMMUNITIES FOR SO LONG.
BUT WE STILL HAVE SO MANY MORE
CHALLENGES AHEAD OF US WE HAVE
IF YOU WILL ANOTHER FIFTY YEARS
THAT WE HAVE TO BEGIN TO THINK
ABOUT. AND I DON'T LIKE THE
BUILT INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH THE
BOARD IS PROBABLY INVESTED SIX
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
THE LAST FIVE YEARS. THAT'S IN
WASTE WATER TREATMENT PLANTS
DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS FOR
WATER CAPTURE. WATER RECYCLING
GROUNDWATER CLEANUP- WE ALSO
HAVE TO REINVEST NOT JUST IN
THE BUILT INFRASTRUCTURE BUT IN
THE PEOPLE INFRASTRUCTURE OUR
INSTITUTIONS. AND THE WAY THAT
WE RESOURCE DOWN TO ACCOMPLISH
THESE REALLY CRITICAL GOALS.
CALIFORNIA HAS LED THE WAY AS
SHOWN THAT. CLEAN AND CLEAN AIR
BE THE- OF. TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY ECONOMY AND HAVE TO BE
THE BASIS FOR OUR MODERN
ECONOMY. BUT WE HAVE AGAIN A
LOT OF WORK STILL LEFT TO DO.
AND SO I'M I'M PROUD AND
FORTUNATE TO BE AT THE BOARD AT
IT AT THIS TIME. I'M I'M DOING
MY BEST TO ENSURE THAT THE
BOARD IS RESPONDING HERE IN
DROUGHT CERTAINLY BOTH IN OUR
CAPACITY. IN WATER RIGHTS IN
OUR ADMINISTRATION OF THEIR OF
BUT ALSO AND IT'S RESPONDING TO
COMMUNITIES WITH DRINKING WATER
CHALLENGES I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT WAS
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
LEGISLATURE THAT BROUGHT THE
DIVISION OF DRINKING WATER TO
THE BOARD. ONLY ABOUT FIVE OR
SIX YEARS AGO AND IN THAT FIVE
TO SIX YEARS I'M PROUD OF THE
WORK THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
DO. THAT MAKE MORE ACCOUNTABLE
THE DRINKING WATER PROGRAM BUT
IMPORTANTLY BEGIN TO REALLY
CLOSE THE GAP. AND THAT WE KNOW
EXIST START COMMUNITIES TOO
OFTEN BASED OFF OF RACE. AND
THAT ACCESS TO CLEAN AND SAFE
WATER AND SANITATION IS THE
BASIS FOR ANY ODERN. ECONOMY
AND FOR ANY ANY COMMUNITY THAT
IS GOING TO HAVE THE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. AT AND SO I JUST WANT
TO THANK THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND IT KNOWLEDGE
THAT THERE ARE A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF CHALLENGES STILL OUT
THERE. BUT I FEEL CONFIDENT WE
THAT WE COLLECTIVELY THROUGH.
OUR OUR MANY INSTITUTIONS
GOVERNING AT THE LOCAL STATE
AND FEDERAL LEVEL CAN CAN MAKE
OUR WAY THROUGH THIS AND
CONTINUE TO CONTRIBUTE TO. THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE WANT TO SEE
IN THE TIME AHEAD SO THANK YOU.
THANK. YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ADDRESS THAT THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL OF
THOSE VERY SUBSTANTIVE OPENING
COMMENTS- SENATOR LAYERED WOULD
YOU LIKE TO KICK US OFF AND
THEN I'LL GO THE VICE CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
STAND. OF I SHOULD SAY JUST AT
THE OUTSET THAT- IT THAT
MISTRUST GIVE ALL WAS DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR FEDERAL WATER
AFFAIRS FOR TWO YEARS WHEN I
WAS SECRETARY FOR NATURAL
RESOURCES AND HE WAS OUR POINT
PERSON ON THE GROUND IN
WASHINGTON WITH. THE FEDERAL
AGENCIES AND MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS AND- HAD AN EXEMPLARY
ROW RECORDS SO JUST IN THIS
DISCUSSION STARTS WITH A LITTLE
HEAD START. OF WITH ME IN TERMS
OF HIS US SERVICE. AND WE HAD A
REALLY GOOD TALK ABOUT THE
SUBSIDIES SHOES AND I WANT TO
GO THROUGH- TWO OR THREE OF
THEM HERE AND WOULD WE HAVE TO
TALK- ARE USED FIVE OF OUR DAYS
DURING THE BREAK. TO HAVE
DOWNTIME AND I WENT TO THE CITY
MENDOCINO ART WHICH WAS IN THE
PROCESS OF DRYING OUT- OF. THEY
ARE I'M CONFIDENT AFTER THIS
DIG THAT THERE'S A GOOD CHANCE
THEY RUN OUT OF WATER BEFORE
THE WINTER COMPLETELY ENOUGH TO
CLOSE DOWN THE CITY AND SO IT
LEADS TO. A LOT OF DISCUSSIONS
BECAUSE OF THE WATER BOARD
JURISDICTION IN THIS AREA. AND
I THOUGHT I'D START WITH JUST.
ARE THE SAFE DRINKING WATER
PROGRAM WAS MOVED FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH TO THE
WATER BOARD BECAUSE OF A BELIEF
THAT NEED NEED TO HAVE A LITTLE
MORE ENERGY. WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS COULD YOU CHARACTERIZE HOW
IT'S BEEN RUNNING- UNDER. THE
WATER BOARD. I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT. THE DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH DID AMAZING WORK WITH
WITH THE DIVISION OF DRINKING
WATER AND SO MY COMMENTS HERE
ARE OUR KNOWLEDGE AND THAT IT
WAS A DISCUSSION HERE AT THE
LEGISLATURE MAYBE WHERE THE
DIVISION OF DRINKING WATER
MIGHT FIT INTO THE FUTURE. AND
HOW AND WHERE AND HOW IT MIGHT
MY BEST ACCOMPLISH SOME OF ITS
MISSION IN THE WATER BOARD'S
WHAT'S HAPPENED BECAUSE OF THE
VISION OF FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
WHICH ALREADY HAD THE STATE
REVOLVING FUNDS WITH THE CLEAN
WATER ACT AT THE ON THE CLEAN
WATER SIDE THOSE ARE. ARE GOING
TO BE IN THE WASTE WATER
TREATMENT PLANTS BUT OTHER
OTHER CLEAN WATER PROJECTS AND-
I JUST HAVE TO SAY THAT IT IT
IS GONE INCREDIBLY WELL I AM
INCREDIBLY. PROUD OF THE WORK
THAT HAS BEEN DONE IN TE LAST
FIVE YEARS THAT'S NO- EXTENSIVE
AMOUNT OF TIME BUT WE IN THAT
TIME WHAT WE HAVE DONE IS BEEN
ABLE TO BEGIN TO ACCELERATE OUR
RESPONSE TO COMMUNITIES THAT.
DIDN'T HAVE ACCESS TO CLEAN
WATER AND THEN WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER THAT THE ISSUE OF
ACCESS TO CLEAN WATER IS A
GENERATIONAL THESE ARE
COMMUNITIES HERE ARE ARE
OFTENTIMES YOU KNOW. TEN TWENTY
YOUR YEARS WITH STRUGGLING WITH
SOME OF THESE CHALLENGES. AND
HERE THE STATE HAS TO THE
LEADERSHIP OF THIS THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
ESTABLISHED YET THE FUND TO
HELP EVEN CLOSE THAT GAP
KNOWING THAT. YOU LOOK AT THE
TRADITIONAL PROGRAMS THAT ARE
AT THE STATE AND FEDERAL LEVELS
AND- YOU USUALLY NEED TO BE A
SYSTEM OF SCIENCE TO HAVE THE
LEGAL. FINANCIAL AND AN
ENGINEERING- IT SORT. BOOKS ON
TAP TO BE ABLE TO PULL THE
PROJECT THROUGH TO COMPLETION
AND FOR COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
STRUGGLING TO COME UP WITH
THOSE RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO
PULL IT BUT BRING A PROGRAM TO
CONSTRUCTION- IT IT IS IT IS
MEANT THAT WE HAVE TO COME UP
WITH GREATER TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND HELP. BRIDGE
BACK THAT DIVIDE AND THAT HAS
BEEN INCREDIBLE WORK TO SEE
HAPPENS IS A DIVISION OF
DRINKING WATERS COME TO THE
BOARD MEMBER SAFER PROGRAM AND.
BECAUSE I BELIEVE WE ARE
STRUCTURE- RIGHT WHICH IS. AS
WELL KNOW OVER SIXTY. GOVERNOR
APPOINT- AT AT THE REGIONAL AND
STATE BOARD LEVEL WHICH AT THE
STATE LEVEL THERE'S FIVE OF US.
BUT YOU KNOW PUBLIC PUBLICLY
ACCOUNTABLE AND APPOINTED
INDIVIDUALS I FEEL JUST IT. IT
MEANS THAT WE JUST HAVE MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE PROGRAM
AND SO- HAVE BEEN VERY
HEARTENED WITH THE WORK THAT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO. WELL
THANK YOU AND IT AS A MATTER OF
FACT WE CONFIRMED A FEW OF
THOSE REGIONAL BOARD MEMBERS IN
THE MOTION WHILE YOU WERE
WAITING SO- SOMETHING WE DO
AND- AND ONE QUICK FOLLOW UP ON
THAT ONE. IT'S OF HI THIS ISSUE
WHEN I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY
THAT. THIS SMALL FARM WORKER
COMMUNITY IN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
HAD CONTAMINATED WATER. AND YET
BECAUSE OF ONE BIG. BUSINESS
INTEREST IN THE AREA THEY WERE
NOT CONSIDERED A DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY AND WE WORKED REALLY
CLOSELY WITH THE WATER FOR TO
MAKE SURE THAT. THE PEOPLE THAT
WOULD DISADVANTAGE BECAME
ELIGIBLE FOR THE MONEY EVEN
THOUGH THAT WASN'T THE INITIAL
TAKE ON THE RULES ARE. WOULD
YOU CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
PEOPLE ON ISSUES LIKE THAT AS
BOARD SO THAT WE CAN JUST TRY
TO. GET JUSTICE WHEN THOSE
SITUATIONS HAPPEN. DEFINITELY
CENTER HIGH NOTES- THAT
SOMETIMES- ARE YOU WE GET
PASSED DOWN RULES FACT HAVE
FROM FROM FROM OUR PROGRAMS
THAT CAN SEEM INFLEXIBLE OR
BUREAUCRATIC. AND I KNOW THAT
WE ARE ALWAYS OPEN VERY MUCH SO
TO ENSURING THAT WE BEST
UNDERSTAND WHERE WHERE
FLEXIBILITY IS INTO VERY MUCH
EXPRESS IT AND I KNOW THAT
THERE'S BEEN A PARTICULARLY
WHEN IT COMES TO. POPULATION
CAPS AND HOW THEY TIE INTO
CERTAIN FUNDING PROGRAMS FOR US
CAN BE SOMETIMES VERY
FRUSTRATING AND CANDIDLY WE
CONTINUE TO SEE LARGER
COMMUNITIES OF SIZE. STRUGGLING
WITH WITH A LOT OF THE SAME
CHALLENGES MANY OF OUR SMALLER
SYSTEMS HAVE BEEN FACING WITH
FOR YEARS AND SO IT'S ALWAYS
GOING TO BE REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR US TO CONTINUE TO BE
FLEXIBLE WITH OUR PROGRAMS AND
MAKE SURE WE DON'T JUST HAVE.
OUR NUMBERS IN PLACE THAT-
DON'T APPROPRIATELY CAPTURED OF
THE NEEDS THANK YOU THANK YOU
N. A. N. IT LEADS TO. THE NEXT
OF MY TWO QUESTIONS AND IT'S
HAS TO DO WITH THE CULTURE AND
I THINK OTHER PEOPLE WILL TALK
ABOUT THE LARGER CULTURE AND
THEIR TWO DIFFERENT ISSUES
DIVERSITY AND OTHERS. THAT THAT
ARE. REALLY WORTHY OF LOOKING
AT BUT- THE ONE WE HAD OUR
MEETING TALKED ABOUT I WAS
AWARE ONE PARTICULAR WATER
RIGHTS SITUATION THAT IS IN MY
HOME AREA THAT TOOK FOUR YEARS
ED AND I TOLD YOU THAT IT WAS
SAID TO ME AFTERWARDS YOU DON'T
UNDERSTAND THIS IS ONE OF THE
QUICKEST ONES WE'VE DONE. IT
AND IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THERE'S
A WHOLE ISSUE OF
RESPONSIVENESS. AND IT IF YOU
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES TO
DO WHAT YOU NEED TO DO
EXPEDITIOUSLY THAT YOU ADD FOR
THEM. ASK FOR THEM COULD YOU
SPEAK TO JUST SORT OF. LIKE THE
CULTURE OF THE AGENCY WITH
REGARD TO BEING RESPONSIVE AND
HOW YOU'VE WORKED ON THAT AND
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE WAYS
YOU'VE ADDRESSED CONCERNS ABOUT
THAT. AT THANK YOU SENATOR. YOU
KNOW I- I WOULD HAVE IT THE
PUBLIC SEE EACH OF THE FIVE
STATE BOARD MEMBERS HAVE SOME
SPECIALIZATION- AND HI MY SEAT
IS THE PUBLIC ONE AND SO I FIND
MYSELF OFTEN. CONTEMPLATING
WHAT IS IT THAT I'M SUPPOSED TO
BE BRINGING THEM TO THE BOARD I
THROUGH THE PUBLIC SEAT AND
RESPONSIVENESS TO THE NEEDS.
ARE AND IN TRANSPARENCY TOWARD
DECISION MAKING ARE SUCH A
STRONG PILLAR TO THAT TO WORK
THE WAY I SEE I REALLY BUT I
NEED TO BRING AS A LENDS TO MY
WORK. SO WHEN IT COMES TO ANY
CRITICISMS AROUND. THAT SORT OF
THE SLOW PACE OF RESPONSE FOR
OR OTHERWISE- I NEED FOR US TO
BE MORE TRANSPARENT IN OUR IN
OUR DECISION MAKING- I TAKE IT
VERY PERSONALLY AND I AND I AND
I TRY TO. UNDERSTAND HOW BEST
WE CAN- WE CAN BRIDGE THAT AND
WHAT I'VE DONE IS FOCUSED ON
OUR OUR WEBSITE OTHER OTHER
WACKY MEANS OF COMMUNICATION
THAT HELP FOLKS UNDERSTAND WHAT
WE'RE DOING AND WHEN. I THINK
THAT WHAT IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER IS THAT TAKES
RESOURCES IN ORDER TO BE
RESPONSIVE AS AN AGENCY. AND
THEY'RE I FEEL VERY FORTUNATE
THAT THROUGH THE SAFER PROGRAM
THE STATION AFFORDABLE FUND WAS
ESTABLISHED WE'VE ACTUALLY BEEN
ABLE TO EXPAND THE NUMBER OF
FOLKS IN OUR- OUR OFFICE OF
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION. AND SO WE
HAVE NOW. ARE MORE INDIVIDUALS
AND IN OUR IN OUR AGENCY THAT
ARE SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED ON
LEARNING TO BETTER BE
RESPONSIVE. HOW LEARNING HOW TO
COMMUNICATE SOMETIMES A VERY
TECHNICAL WORK AT THE BOARD IN
A WAY THAT UP AT COMMUNITIES
CAN UNDERSTAND OR SEE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS AND KNOW THAT.
THERE ARE DIFFERENT AUDIENCES
AND LEVELS OF INFORMATION THAT
WE NEED TO BECOME BANG SO THAT
ARE KIND OF HIGHER LEVEL THE OF
THE OFFICE OF PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION CONTINUE TO HAVE
RESOURCES LIKE. IN OUR WEBSITE
TO BE BETTER AND MORE
RESPONSIVE HAS BEEN IMPORTANT.
BUT IT REALLY DEPENDS ON THE
PROGRAM. THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT AS WELL IMPORTANT TO FOR
THAT WE HAVEN'T OF WATER RIGHTS
OF WAY QUALITY. OF DRINKING
WATER AND FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
AND EACH ONE OF THOSE- MAY HAVE
DIFFERENT CHALLENGES WHEN IT
COMES TO- THE RESPONSIVENESS OF
THE WORK OF THE PROJECT. BUT
ALWAYS VERY OPEN TO HELPING TO
UNDERSTAND. HOW WE CAN BE
BETTER AND MORE RESPONSIVE. AND
I'M SURE WE WANT TO WORK WITH
YOU OVER TIME AND AS PRICKLY
AROUND BUDGET ISSUES AND OTHER
THINGS JUST MAKE SURE THAT THIS
IS. IN THE RIGHT PLACE AND MY
LAST QUESTION. IS OBVIOUSLY AND
I BET EVERYBODY WANNA TALK
ABOUT THIS ON THE COMMITTEE THE
COMMITTEE WERE IN THE MIDDLE OF
A DROUGHT. A RATHER SEVERE ONE.
AND I READ THE NEWS ACCOUNTS OF
THE BOARD'S DECISION WITH
REGARD TO THE FIRST. DELTA
WATER RIGHTS. AND I HAD SOME
CONCERNS BASED ON THE NEWS
ACCOUNTS AND SO IN OUR MEETING
I ASKED YOU ABOUT IT AND- IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT THERE WERE A
LOT OF OTHER THINGS THAT MORE
IN EVIDENCE IN THE NEWSPAPER
ACCOUNTS THAT HELP EXPLAIN THIS
DECISION AND ONE OF THE
SURPRISES TO ME. WAS WHEN I
HEARD THAT MY CLOSE FRIEND TOM
BIRMINGHAM AND WESTLANDS WATER
DISTRICT SUPPORTED WHAT THE
BOARD DID WHICH YOU WOULD NOT
GET FROM THE NEWSPAPER ACCOUNTS
AND SO I WAS WONDERING. IF YOU
MIGHT TALK A LITTLE ABOUT THAT
IN A WAY THAT. THAT WE COULD
CLEARLY UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU DID
HOW PEOPLE WIND UP AND WHAT THE
IMPACT OF YOUR DECISION IS
GOING TO BE. THANK YOU SENATOR
I'LL TRY MY BEST TO DISTINCT
AND BRIEF- WATER RIGHTS. AND IF
THE DISCUSSION AROUND IT CAN
CAN TAKE UP A LOT OF SPACE BUT
I THINK IT'S THERE'S A PRETTY
SPENT SIMPLE FUNDAMENTALS.
AMONGST THAT WORK AS AS WE ALL
KNOW THAT WATER RATES SYSTEM IS
HOW WE ALLOCATE WATER IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND YEAH
IT IS IT IS NOT LOST ON ME BUT
IS ACTUALLY ONLY THE THIRD
TIME. IN THIS TRIAL NOW THAT
THE BOARD HAS ACTUALLY
CURTAILED RIGHTS MEANING WE'VE
WE'VE WE'VE HOTEL BECAUSE THE
HYDROLOGY IS SO POOR. AND
OTHERWISE WE HAVE A PRETTY
LIGHT TOUCH ON OUR WATER RATES
ADMINISTRATION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IT'S ONLY A FEW
YEARS AGO THAT WE BEGAN
REQUIRING YEARLY REPORTING FROM
ALL OF OUR WATER RIGHTS HOLDERS
OTHER DIVERSIONS FROM THE PRIOR
YEAR SO YOU THINK OF A WATER
RIGHTS SYSTEM IN ITS
ADMINISTRATION. IT IT CAN BE
PRETTY SIMPLE HERE IT'S ABOUT
WHO'S TAKING WHAT OUT OF THE
SYSTEM AND WHEN AND- MEETING IT
TO BE A TAG TO WHAT'S ACTUALLY
HYDROLOGICALLY AVAILABLE. AND
THAT'S ACTUALLY A VERY
COMPLICATED THING AS SIMPLE OF
A CONCEPT IS A CAN SOUND. AND
SO- THERE'S JUST A INCREDIBLE
NEED FOR US TO CONTINUE TO
ENSURE THAT THE WATER RIGHT
SYSTEM IS HERE AND CAN BE
RESPONSIVE. IN THE FACE OF
DROUGHT IN THE FACE OF CLIMATE
CHANGE AND SO THE BOARD'S
ACTION WAS TO. DO WHAT WE CAN
ALL SEE THAT QUITE CLEARLY
WHICH IS THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
WATER TO FILL ALL THE RIGHTS IN
THE WATERSHED. AND SO WE NEED
TO BEGIN TO CURTAIL THOSE IN A
WAY THAT HELP US KEEP GAP TO
PROTECT THEM AND KEEPING
CRITICAL ARTICLES HERE IN MIND
WHICH ARE LIKE. WHICH INCLUDES
KEEPING WATER UP IN OUR
RESERVOIRS WHAT WE WERE SEEING
WAS AN INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF
DEPLETIONS MEANING WATER THAT
WAS BEING. RELEASED FROM THE
RESERVOIRS WASN'T MAKING IT TO
THE DELTA DEPLETIONS BEFORE
WATER MADE OUT TO THE DELTA SO.
IT WAS OBVIOUS THAT THE BOARD
WAS NEEDING TO ACT- BECAUSE WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO PRESERVE AS
MUCH WATER NOW AS WE CAN IN OUR
RESERVOIRS IN ANTICIPATION. OF
A CONTINUED DR YEAR. AND SO-
YEAH THE COVER. I MAYBE
SOMETIMES MAKE ITS KIND OF A
GOOD OR BLACK BAD BLACK OR
WHITE SORT OF- ACTION AND THAT
THE BOARD DID SOMETHING THAT
WAS VERY RIVAS OR INTEREST TO.
A LOT OF- THE COMMUNITIES OUT
THERE FARMERS PARTICULARLY. AND
I THINK WHAT IS BIG THE-
REALITY IS THAT WE NEED TO BE.
AT ENSURING THAT THE WATER
RATES SYSTEM IS WORKING THAT WE
NEED TO BE CURTAILING IN TIMES
OF DROUGHT. THAT'S HOW WE
PROTECT ALL OF OURSELVES
COLLECTIVELY OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND THE WATER RIGHTS SYSTEM
ITSELF. AND THAT'S WHY YOU SAW
A NUMBER OF- AGRICULTURAL
INTERESTS ACTUALLY INCLUDING
THE SACRAMENTO VALLEY- ED
CONTRACTORS AND GROWERS. BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BOARD'S
ACTION NOT BECAUSE AGAIN THIS
IS SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE.
REQUIRES US TO ACTUALLY ENSURE
THAT. INDIVIDUALS ARE TAKING
WATER OUT OF THE SYSTEM WHEN
THEY DON'T HAVE A LEGAL RIGHT
TO IT OR WHEN WE'RE NOT ABLE
ABLE TO MEET- REALLY CRITICAL.
NEED TURNER NEEDS. MORE THANK
YOU BECAUSE I THINK THAT ANSWER
JUST SPOKE TO THE COMPLEXITY OF
THE SITUATION. THE FACT THAT
DID IT IS MORE UNDERSTANDABLE I
APPRECIATE THE- OPPORTUNITY TO
BE ABLE TO ASK THESE QUESTIONS
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO.
SUPPORTING THE CANDIDATE WE GET
TO ABOUT. THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED MADAM BY SHERIFF. THANK
YOU AND- THANK YOU MR VAL- FOR
YOUR- COMMITMENT TO WHAT I
CONSIDER TO BE ONE OF THE MOST
COMPLEX POLICY ISSUES. WE HAVE
LEGISLATORS LEGISLATORS HAVE TO
DEAL WITH SO IT'S BEEN
CHALLENGING TO ME BECAUSE I DO
NOT. I'M NOT I'M NOT IN AN AREA
THAT IS- CERTAINLY WERE
CHALLENGED BUT NOT TO THE
DEGREE THAT HAS GONE ON WITH
THE DELTA AND ALL OF ON THE ON
THE IMPACT OF BAD EFFECT I'M-
REPRESENTAR. COUNTY AND SAN
DIEGO AND BOTH OF THOSE COUNTY
STAND OUT I BELIEVE IN
ADDRESSING. THE PREVENTION THE
LONGER TERM- WATER RESOURCES
NEEDS ORANGE COUNTY A LEADER IN
THE RECYCLED WATER TO RECHARGE
THE GROUNDWATER AQUIFERS. EX
EXTREMELY- SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM
AND CERTAINLY AND SAN DIEGO AND
IN MY DISTRICT IN CARLSBAD. AB
SOUTH PLANTATION BUT BASICALLY
THE DREAMABOUT I STARTED WHEN
I WAS A MEMBER OF THE ASSEMBLY
BACK IN THE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS. AND BECAME REALITY
WHEN I'VE GOT TO THE SENATE SO-
FIRST OF ALL YOU HAVE TO HAVE
THE IDEA OF THE DREAMS THAT YOU
CAN DO THESE THINGS AND- THEN
THEY THEY DO A FINALLY APPEAR
BAD INCETIVE IS NEEDED.
RESOURCES FINANCIAL ARE NEEDED
AND CERTAINLY COMMITMENT OF OUR
POLICYMAKERS ARE NEEDED. SO MY
QUESTION A YEAR OF. DOES THE
BOARD HAVE A ROLE- HANNAH. AT
INCENTIVIZING IN ADVANCING OF
THESE TYPE OF PROJECTS AS WE
SEE OURSELVES IN THE FOOT BEER
DROUGHT NOW. IN CERTAINLY- IT
IS CYCLICAL WE KNOW THAT WE ARE
A DESERT. COMMITTED OURSELVES
TO SOMETHING. BEAUTIFUL THE
OTHER BAD TOM THERE'S ALWAYS
GOING TO BE THE ISSUE WITH
WHERE DO WE GET WATER WHEN WE
HIT ONE OF THESE AND THESE TWO
PROGRAMS ARE SEEM TO HAVE. GONE
UP QUITE A DEFENSE IN
ADDRESSING THAT YET THEY SEEM
TO BE THE ONLY ONES THAT STAND
OUT IN THE STATE AND I I'M
WONDERING IF THE BOARD DOESN'T
HAVE A ROLE THERE SHOULDN'T
HAVE A ROLE IN INCENTIVIZING
MORE OF THEIR FOR. ESPECIALLY
IN OUR CENTRAL VALLEY SO I KIND
OF LAID OUT IN YOUR LAP AND
I'LL LOVE TO HEAR YOUR THOUGHTS
ON THAT AND WHAT YOU MIGHT DO-
ALICE THE TEAR. THE LEADER
GOING FORWARD TO- I I'M GONNA
SAY GET A BETTER PERSPECTIVE
ALL A BETTER CONCEPT AND A
BETTER ACCEPTANCE THAT THESE
ARE NOT THINGS THAT. YOU KNOW
ARE SO DETRIMENTAL TO THE
ENVIRONMENT AS HAVE BEEN
CHARACTERIZED PERHAPS SOMEONE
LIKE MY COLLEAGUES. ARE
MENTIONED ABOUT HOW THE DELTA.
OF BABEL SIGNED WITH
MISPERCEPTIONS SO- LET ME HEAR
YOUR THOUGHTS. THANK YOU SOME
FASTER- WE HAVE A AND
THANKFULLY AND PROBABLY HAVE
BEEN CONTRIBUTING TO THESE
WATER RECYCLING PROJECTS BOTH
FINANCIALLY AND REGULATORY-
I'LL NOTE THAT WE ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING ON REGULATIONS TO MOVE
TO DIRECT POTABLE REUSE- AS YOU
KNOW. AS CENTER THOSE THAT THE
PROJECTS THAT WE HAVE CURRENTLY
IN THE STATE ARE INDIRECT-
WATER RECYCLING WHEN IT COMES
TO DRINKING WATER MEANING. THAT
IT EITHER GOES TO A GROUNDWATER
BASIN LIKE AN ORANGE COUNTY- OR
MIGHT GO TO A DRINKING WATER
RESERVOIR BEFORE MAKING IT TO
THAN A DRINKING WATER TREATMENT
PLANT- AND WE HAVE PROJECTS
LIKE THAT IN SAN DIEGO. AND
ANOTHER OTHERS POPPING UP IN
THE STATE. AB WHAT WORD THE
NEXTGENERATION OF PROJECTS
WILL BE OUR DIRECT POTABLE
REUSE PROJECTS MEANING. THAT
THE WATER THAT'S RECYCLED WILL
GO DIRECTLY INTO DISTRIBUTION
AND DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS.
THIS IS A HUGELY HI IT IS NOT
DONE LIGHTLY WORK FOR
CENTURIES- AT MELANIA- WE HAVE
KNOWN THAT WE HAVE TO SEPARATE
OUR SANITATION SYSTEMS AND OUR
DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS. AND TO
COMBINE THE CHU IS TIPPED TO
OPEN UP. THE POSSIBILITY FOR
PATHOGENS AND OTHER CHALLENGES
AND SO. WHAT THIS OUR STATE HAS
BEEN A LEADER AND IS STRIVING
WATER RECYCLING PROJECTS. AND
NOW THESE DIRECT POTABLE REUSE
PROJECTS ARE THAT NEXT
GENERATION SO AS WE DEVELOP
THOSE REGULATIONS WE ALREADY
SEE PROJECTS IN LOS ANGELES.
AND WITH WITH THE METROPOLITAN
WATER DISTRICT AND L. A. COUNTY
SAN COMING TO PROVE THAT BEEN
DISCUSSING COMING TO FRUITION.
AND OTHER PLACES IN THE STATE
THAT WILL TAKE THESE
REGULATIONS AND DEVELOP THAT
NEXT GENERATION OF PROJECTS. SO
WE HAVE TO BE READY TO INVEST
IN THEM AND WHAT WE NEED TO
HAVE BEEN. CONTINUING TO ADD WE
HAVE A RECYCLE WATER POLICY AT
THE STATE WATER BOARD- WE'RE
LOOKING TO BE UPDATING THAT WE
RECENTLY MADE SOME CHANGES
GIVEN TO DATA GATHERING. SO
THAT WE BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW
MUCH WATER RECYCLING IS GOING
ON IN THE STATE AND CONTINUE TO
YOU PRIVATE. AND METRIC WHY
IT'S NOT ON MY WE DO WITH
OXNARD CHANGE GOALS YOU KNOW
THE MEASURE IT LET'S LET'S THE
POLICY. AND THE PHOENIX OF IT
AND WITH WATER RECYCLING.
RECORD YOUR COMPLETELY SPOT ON
CENTER THOSE ARE THESE ARE THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY PROJECTS
THAT WE NEED TO BE DEVELOPING
AND INVESTING AS WE MAKE THIS
GENERATIONAL REINVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE. ARE GOING TO
HELP MAXIMIZE OUR SUPPLIES GET
US THROUGH BROWSE AND CONTINUE
TO TAKE HIM BACK SEMIS JUST THE
USE OF THE RESOURCES. WE HAVE
AT HAND NOW AND I THINK THERE
IS AN INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY TO
DO THAT AND YOUR POINT THE
CENTRAL VLLEY. HAS ACTUALLY A
COUPLE OF PROJECTS OUT THERE
BUT NEEDS AND THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITY FOR A LOT MORE AND
SO WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
UNDERSTAND HOW BEST TO INVEST
IN THOSE IMPROPER THAT THE
BOARD. AND BANKS WILL TO THE
LEGISLATURE FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND THE GOVERNOR FOR. PROVIDING
THE BOARD ONE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS NOW IN
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR WASTE WATER
DRINKING WATER SYSTEM. AND
LOOKING TO SEE HOW WE CAN ALSO
BROKE OUT FOR WATER RECYCLING.
AND WHAT ABOUT THE CELL SINCE
THAT'S BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN OTHER
COUNTRIES AND CERTAINLY ALL THE
SAN DIEGO- EXPERIENCE FIVE HAS
BEYOND ALL QUITE SUCCESSFUL.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT. YEAH I
THINK THAT LIKE. IT IS A TOOL
AND IT IS AN IMPORTANT ONE I AM
FOR COMMUNITIES TO ASSESS SOME
MONTHS THEIR PORTFOLIO OF WATER
PROJECTS OUT THERE IMPORTANTLY
THE BOARD ACTUALLY HAS A D.
CELL POLICY- IT IS THE
REGULATORY STRUCTURE BY WHICH-
PROJECTS MAKE THEIR WAY AFTER
REGIONAL WATER QUALITY CONTROL
BOARD AND I THINK THAT. WHAT IS
PROBABLY AN AND HELPFUL IN THE
OFFING IS MAYBE A DISCUSSION
ABOUT UPDATING THAT POLICY TO
SAY HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT IT'S
THEIR TO CONTINUE TO. PROTECT
CERTAINLY OUR WATER RESOURCES
THAT YOU NEED TO THINK ABOUT
THAT IN THE LONG TERM FOR ALL
OF OUR PROJECTS AND ALL OF OUR
WATERSHEDS BUT HOW DO WE THEN
ALSO INCENTIVIZE THOSE PROJECTS
THAT DON'T DO THAT HARM AND I
THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT THING
TED TO CONTINUE TO BETTER
FIGURE OUT. AND UNLOCK. OPTION
OF THE CELL IN THE STATE NOW
SAY THAT THERE ARE EXAMPLES OF
A NUMBER OF. SMALLER PROJECTS
THAT I AM AWARE OF THAT ARE OUT
THERE THAT ARE CONTINUE TO SHOW
THE INNOVATION AND
SUPPLEMENTING LOCAL WATER
PORTFOLIOS WITH THE SOUTH END
OF BRACKISH WATER THE CELEBRATE
AS WELL AND WE JUST NOTE AND
NOT TO JUST. TALK TO MUCH BUT I
KNOW THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
ENERGY AS A NEW PROGRAM-
LOCATED HERE IN THE STATE TO BE
ABLE TO ADVANCE THE TECHNOLOGY
OF THE CELL BRACKISH YOU SELL
BEGIN TO CONTINUE. TO ENSURE
THAT THESE PROJECTS ARE HERE
FOR US. WELL THANK YOU FOR ON
YOUR ANSWERS THOSE SO WERE- OF
TOP PRIORITY COME. OF MINE SO
THANKS AGAIN AND CERTAINLY FOR
YOUR SERVICE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MADAM VICE CHAIR SENATOR
GROWTH. THANK YOU MADAM FOR
TEN- WELL WELCOME SIR
DEFINITELY TO THE COMMITTEE AND
MISSED A LOT OF NICE THINGS
ABOUT YOU BEFORE I START
QUESTIONING YOU. SO I DO WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ALWAYS BEING RESPONSIVE- YOU
IMMEDIATELY PROVIDED STAFF WITH
YOUR CELL PHONE NUMBER AND WE
HAVE THE CATASTROPHE IN NEEDLES
VERY POOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY ON THE ARIZONA BORDER
THAT IS IN MY DISTRICT. AND
WHOSE LOST ITS ONLY OPERATING
WELL AND THEN. WHEN I EXPLAINED
WHAT WAS GOING ON YOU ALREADY
HAD YOUR HANDS AROUND IT AND-
ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS YOU
SAID IS THAT- I DOESN'T MATTER
WHERE YOU LIVE IN CALIFORNIA
WATER IS A BASIC HUMAN RIGHT.
AND SO I REALLY DID APPRECIATE
THAT VERY MUCH BECAUSE
SOMETIMES WE STRUGGLE- S.
THINKING THAT YEAH YOU KNOW
MAYBE REPUBLICAN TO SIX AREN'T
AS- YOU KNOW AS IF I WAS A
FAVORITE BUT NOT AS WELL TAKE
CARE OF AS DEMOCRATS DISTRICTS
BUT USER HAVE- GONE BEYOND. ANY
AGENCY THAT I'VE EVER WORKED
WITH AND THAT HAS GONE ABOVE
AND BEYOND TO MAKE SURE THAT-
PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT HAVE BEEN
TAKING CARE OF INCLUDING- THE
NEEDLE SITUATION THAT WE HAD
AND SOME OF THE STUFF UP AND
TULARE COUNTY. SO I DO WANT TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT I
ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING TO ME ABOUT THE
ILLEGAL MARIJUANA GROWS AND HOW
I FELT LIKE THAT WAS AN ISSUE
THAT THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD KIT ADDRESS. I DO
TOO- YOU KNOW THE ILLEGAL- AT
THE ILLEGAL ACTIVITY THAT GOES
ON DIGGING WELLS THAT ARE
PERMITTED. TAKING WATER THAT'S
NOT YOU KNOW THAT'S NOT THEIR
WATER TO TAKE- AND- YOU KNOW
WHEN WE BUST THESE ILLEGAL.
MARIJUANA GROWS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I HAD FOUND OUT. IS
THAT TIME TO HAVING A
CONVERSATION WITH YOU YOU
EDUCATED ME ON WHAT WAS IN YOUR
PURVIEW AND WAS IN A LOCAL PER
VIEW SO THAT WAS VERY
BENEFICIAL AS WELL. SO I JUST
FIRST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
ALWAYS BEING AVAILABLE THANK
YOU FOR- SCHERING YOUR CELL
PHONE NUMBER YOU MAY REGRET
THAT ONE DAY. WE HAVE M. M. BIG
CATASTROPHIC WATER ISSUES AND
THAT ARE NEEDING TO BE
ADDRESSED BUT M. I APPRECIATE
YOUR WISDOM ON EVERYONE OF
SUBJECT MATTER SAID I IF I'M
BROUGHT TO YOU. SO- AND- SO-
FIRST QUESTION I WOULD ASK YOU
IS ABOUT THE ILLEGAL MARIJUANA
GROWS WE DID TALK A LITTLE BIT
WE EXCHANGED SOME TEXT MESSAGES
AND EMAILS AND YOU SAID YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE YOUR STAFF REACH OUT
TO ME- ABOUT IT OR MY STAFF A
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT- I
THOUGHT MAYBE IN YOUR PURVIEW
IS THE ILLEGAL CHEMICAL- THAT
CARBON FUERAN WILL QUARTER
TEASPOON WILL KILL AN ADULT
PERSON AND IT'S ONE OF THE
HIGHLY CONTAMINATED CHEMICALS
THAT ARE FOUND IN THESE ILLEGAL
MARIJUANA GROWS. AND I KNOW
WITH PROPOSITION FORTY SEVEN-
THOUSANDS OF THESE GROWS HAVE
ENDED UP ON OUR DESERT FLOOR HE
CAME IN- THERE SQUATTERS MOSTLY
AS A IT'S NOT SOMEBODY YOU KNOW
WE'D LIKE TO GO AFTER THE LAND
LEASE THERE'S LANDOWNERS IF
THEY'RE LEASING PEOPLE THAT ARE
DOING YOU KNOW LISTEN TO PEOPLE
AND FIND A WAY TO STOP THAT THE
MAJORITY OF THEM ARE JUST
SQUATTERS ON OUR DESERT ALLEY
FLOOR HE CAME IN AND THEY JUST
PLOW DOWN EVERY JOSHUA TREE IN
SIGHT AND WHEN SMALL
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES HAVE
TO PAY YOU KNOW THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS FOR A JOSHUA TREE
REMOVAL IN ORDER TO HOOK UP TO
THIS SYSTEM WATER DO YOU KNOW
THAT SEWER SYSTEM. AND BECAUSE
REQUIRED TO BY LAW AND IS THE
CHEMICAL BASE GETTING BACK. TO
YOUR PER VIEW OR A DIFFERENT
WATER AND AGENCY. IT WOULD IT
WOULD DEPEND ON- THE ACTUAL
INCIDENT- AND HERE WE ARE
GETTING ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
TO KIND OF HE'S OUT- WHERE
AUTHORITIES ARE BUT I KNOW WHEN
IT COMES TO WATER QUALITY
VIOLATIONS AND THAT'S WHY WE
ARE WORKING WITH COUNTIES ON
ILLEGAL GROWS AND GO RIDING
ALONG ON ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS IS
BECAUSE THERE ARE WATER QUALITY
VIOLATIONS AND WAR. WHEN IT
COMES TO ILLEGAL DIVERSIONS OF
SURFACE WATER PERHAPS- THOSE
ARE OR WHERE OUR FORTIES OUR
FIRMEST THE CHALLENGE BECOMES
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT ILLEGAL
WELLS AND OR- GROUNDWATER BUT
WE'LL MAKE SURE TO FURTHER
TEASE OUT BUT I KNOW FOR SURE
THAT WE DO HAVE A ROLE WHEN IT
COMES TO ENFORCING AND
RESPONDING TO WATER QUALITY
CHALLENGES ALONG WITH SOME OF
THE NUMBER OF OUR SISTER
AGENCIES- THAT HANDLE
PESTICIDES AND TOXICS AS WELL
SO- WILL BE GLAD TO MAKE SURE
AND WE GET. BACK TO YOU I JUST
MORE DETAIL AROUND WHAT ARE
AUTHORITIES ARE AND WHAT CASES
THE BOARD CAN HELP WHEN IT
COMES TO ENFORCEMENT THANK YOU
I'M THINKING AGAIN AND LIKE I
SAID EARLIER YOU KNOW YOU ARE
VERY KNOWLEDGEABLE AND I
APPRECIATE ALL THE INFORMATION
THAT YOU SHARED WITH ME. AND
THANK YOU FOR THAT COMMENT ON
THAT THE WATER GROUND WATER
CONTAMINATION BECAUSE MY
DISTRICT IS VERY VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT SPECIFICALLY THAT
CHEMICAL THAT THEY FEEL IS
GOING INTO THE GROUND WATER.
AND THAT'S MY DESERT COMMUNITY
I ALSO REPRESENT THE SECOND
LARGEST FOOD PRODUCING COUNTY
IN THE WORLD A KERN COUNTY AND
IN TULARE COUNTY IS THIRD
FRESNO IS FIRST. BUT WE KIND OF
STAIR STEP DOWN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IN THIS RECENT WATER
TRUMP KERR ACREE TELLEMENT-
ORDERS BY THE STDC RCB HAS.
KIND OF PUT SOME OF OUR GROWERS
IN A LITTLE BIT OF A PANIC IN
SO I JUST WONDERED WHEN
DECISIONS ARE MADE LIKE THIS
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE A LIST IN
FRONT OF ME RIGHT NOW BUT I CAN
PROVIDE IT TO YOU. THERE ARE
SEVERAL COMMODITIES GROWN
COMMODITIES THAT ARE GROWN IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY THAT WE GROW.
99% OF THAT FOOD SOURCE. 99% OF
ALMONDS THE LONG. STASHED USE
NINETY NINE. OF THE CUTIES THE
HALOS. M. 99% OF SEVERAL
DIFFERENT I THINK THERE'S OVER
FORTY COMMODITIES THAT WE GROW.
IF WE DON'T GROW THOSE
COMMODITIES IT ACTUALLY AND I
KNOW IT SOUNDS KIND OF
OUTLANDISH BUT IF YOU THINK
ABOUT IT. JUST BASIC AND SIMPLE
IF WE IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY OR
THAT WE GROW YOU KNOW 99% EASE
PRODUCTS AND WE DON'T GROW
THEM. BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO WATER WHICH IS
REQUIRED TO ALLOW THEM TO GROW.
AND WHAT HOW DOES THAT DISRUPT
THE FOOD SUPPLY AND ARE YOU. IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH OTHER STATES
IN THE NATION OR THE
ADMINISTRATION. REGARDING A
POSSIBLE DISRUPTION OF THE FOOD
SUPPLY FOR THESE COMMODITIES
ARE ONLY GROWN IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY THEY'RE NOT RECEIVING
WATER. THANK YOU SENATOR YEAH
THE CONSEQUENCES OF THIS
DROUGHT AND THE PRESSURES THAT
IT'S PUTTING ON ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND THE AG SECTOR
IS VERY FRONT OF MIND AND- YOU
KNOW WE AT THE BOARD- WHEN IT
COMES TO CURTAILMENT. I THINK
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT. IF
THE BOARD DIDN'T CURTAIL IT
WOULD MEANT THAT WE WOULD
CONTINUE TO SEE. PEOPLE PULLING
WATER OUT OF THE SYSTEM THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE REAL LEGAL
RIGHT TO AND- I THINK THAT- AND
I APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS CAN
BE THAT THE BOARD'S ACTION
ITSELF. THAT CAN LEAD TO THESE
THESE THESE CHALLENGES THESE
ISSUES WHEN IT COMES TO-
DESTRUCTION OR JUST TRULY THEY
ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCES AND-
IMPACT THAT HAS ON ON LOCAL
COMMUNITIES- WHEN. THOSE TAX
REVENUES IN THOSE JOBS AREN'T
THERE IN THE AG SECTOR BECAUSE
OF DROUGHT- AND SO KNOW THAT
YOU KNOW I VERY MUCH YOUR THE
FRUSTRATION OF THE BOARD'S
ACTIONS. AND A FEELING THAT
THEY ARE THE CAUSE OF THESE
ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCES BUT I
THINK WE HAVE TO AGAIN REMEMBER
THAT. THE PROUDEST IS CAUSING
INORDINATE AMOUNT OF IMPACT IN
OUR COMMUNITIES I THINK WE HAVE
TO BE READY TO RESPOND AND SO.
THERE I THINK WE DO NEED TO SEE
SUPPORT FOR A BI I COMMUNITY
SAID TO WHETHER THIS DROUGHT
BUT IMPORTANTLY WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT THE LONG
TERM. ON HOW WE CAN BEST
IMPLEMENT SIGMOD IN A WAY THAT
IT IS FAIR BUT RECOGNIZES THAT.
WE WE'VE MET OUR PHYSICAL
LIMITS IN MANY WAYS IN THE
STATE AND NEED TO. BEGIN TO
REALLY RESPOND TO AN
ACKNOWLEDGE- THE CLIMATE CRISIS
THAT WE HAVE. SO WHEN IT COMES
TO FOOD AND DISRUPTION OR THE
POSSIBILITY OF THIS DROUGHT
WHICH IS WEST WIDE AS YOU KNOW
SENATOR- AND WHAT THAT MEANS-
I. IT IS FURTHER DISCUSSION TO
HAVE AND I APPRECIATE THE FLAG
ON THAT- AND WOOD. REMEMBER
THAT THINGS LIKE FOR. ARE
ACTUALLY WE BASS MANAGE THROUGH
DIFFICULT TIMES LIKE DROUGHT IN
A WAY THAT- DOESN'T JUST LEAVE
US AS HONOR A RACE TO THE
BOTTOM- AND WE HAVE TO. BE VERY
AWARE AND ACKNOWLEDGING
ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCES AND
IMPACTS FOR COMMUNITIES AND
RESPOND TO THEM. AND SUPPORT
THEM. BOTH HERE IN THE SHORT
TERM CERTAINLY YOU KNOW AT THE
EMERGENCY DRINKING WATER WORKED
RICHMOND COMES TO MIND ON ON
HOW- WE'RE NEEDING TO RESPOND
BUT IT IS THE LARGER.
DISCUSSION AROUND OUR ECONOMIES
AND HOW BEST TO CONTINUE. TO
HELP THEM TRANSITION TO THE
REAR. OF THIS KIND OF. IS
CANNOT I ALONG THE CAN I ACROSS
IN THERE BECAUSE- KNOW THE ONE
THE BENEFITS OF GOING. THE I TO
PICK DO IS QUESTION HAS BEEN
ASKED DON'T REALLY HAVE TO. BUT
ALONG THE CURTAILMENT- LINE OF
QUESTIONING AS IT RELATES TO
THE IPACTS ON AGATE URBAN
WATER USERS. I HAVE A SIMPLE
QUESTION AND IT MAYBE IT'S A
NAIVE QUESTION BUT- IS THERE
WATER OUT THERE THEY CAN BE
PURCHASED TO BE PUT INTO THE
PUBLIC WATER BANK AND USED TO
HELP. OUT ALL ALONG THESE LINES.
THANK YOU SENATOR FROM UTAH
SAID IN THEIR- AT THANK YOU
CENTER WILL BOWL FIRST WITH ALL
THE KNOWLEDGE WHEN IT COMES TO
OUR CURTAILMENTS WHICH AGAIN-
REGARDING WATER RIGHTS SO
THAT'S IF YOU KNOW SOMEONE HAS
A RIGHT TO SURFACE FLOW IN
THEIR THIRD THEY'RE DIVERTING
AT- AND USING IT IN MANY TIMES
THAT MAY BE A CITY. AND SO IN
OUR CURTAILMENT ORDERS WHICH
HAVE AN EXEMPTION FOR HUMAN
HEALTH AND SAFETY SO- CITIES
ARE EXEMPTED FROM FROM THE
CURTAILMENT AND IS- AND IN MANY
WAYS THE CURTAILMENT IS THERE
TO HELP PROTECT- SOURCES FOR
HUMAN HEALTH AND SAFETY THERE I
THINK OF THE RUSSIAN RIVER AND
THE WORK THAT WE'VE DONE AND
HOW. WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE
PRETENDING WE DIDN'T MEET
STORAGE TARGETS AND IT'S TO
PREVENT DOWNSTREAM CITIES FROM
BEING DISCONNECTED FROM THE
RIVER AND THEIR SOURCE OF
WATER- SO WE'RE WE'RE DOING
THAT IN IN BEING PROTECTED IN
THE WATER RIGHT SPACE
ADDITIONALLY THERE IS I KNOW
DISCUSSION I AND THIS IS MORE
WITH OUR OPERATORS OF THE STATE
WATER PROJECT WE HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT REALLY MOVE
WATER AROUND IN THE STATE. AND
THAT WE WORK WITH I'M DIRECTLY
AND I'VE I'VE HAD CONVERSATION
WITH DIRECTOR NAME AT AND I WAS
UNDERSTAND THERE IS SOME SOME
DISCUSSION OUT THERE ARE MONTHS
URBAN'S AROUND THE POTENTIAL
FOR A WATER BANK IF YOU WILL IN
THERE YOUR POINT IT'S YOU KNOW
HOW BEST TO. HAVE A POOL OF
WATER AT LEAST FOR THOSE THAT
ARE CONNECTED TO THE STATE
WATER PROJECT- IN ORDER TO
ACCESS AND IN THESE DIFFICULT
TIMES SO- MULTI PRONGED THERE
AND THE BOARD'S PURVIEW AGAIN
WE'RE WE'RE WE HAVE AND ALL OF
OUR CALVET ORDERS HUMAN HEALTH
AND SAFETY EXEMPTION SO THAT
CITIES ARE ARE PRIORITIZED AND
IF YOU WILL AND. IN THEIR
ACCESS IN THE WATERS. NO
PROBLEM MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION TO- THERE'S A
WATER BREAK IN MY- I KNOW YOU
PROBABLY ARE AWARE OF THAT. AND
WATER MAKING MY DISTRICT
SOMEBODY STERN LYNDA RESNICK
AND- THEY'VE BEEN DRINKING
WATER FOR. QUITE AWHILE AND- SO
ANOTHER THING THAT I HAD THAT I
WANTED TO ASK YOU IS- YOU KNOW
ONE OF THE MAIN COMPLAINTS THAT
I GET FROM MY GROWERS- IN MY
FARMERS THAT PRODUCE FOOD IS A-
THE ISSUE THAT. EVEN THOUGH
THIS CURTAILMENT THERE ARE
UNDER CONTRACT WHERE THEY PAY A
CERTAIN OLLAR AMOUNT AND
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE ENTITLED
TO A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF WATER.
BUT EVEN THOUGH THE WATER HAS
OVER THELAST FEW YEARS BEEN
CUT BACK THEY STILL HAVE TO PAY
FOR THAT WATER. A PERFECT
EXAMPLE IS LIKE GOING TO THE
GROCERY STORE AND PUT IN A
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR THE
GROCERIES ON THE ON THE BELT
AND- PAYING FOR THAT GETTING IT
BACKED UP AND THEN WALKING OUT
WITH NOTHING- IN THIS CASE OR
5% OF WHAT YOU PURCHASED. IS
THERE AN- IT'S KIND OF IT I
KNOW IT'S A LOADED QUESTION
BUT- IS THERE ANY DISCUSSIONS
GOING ON TO REDUCE THE- PRICE
THAT- OUR WATER USERS ARE END
USERS ARE PAIN. SINCE THEY'RE
NOT GETTING THE WATER IT THEY
WERE PROMISED TO GET. AT THANK
YOU I IMPORTANT HERE- TED TO
DIFFERENTIATE THAT THERE ARE
THOSE THAT ARE ON PROJECT WATER
SO EITHER A LOCAL PROJECT FOR
THE STATE WATER PROJECT OR THE
CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT- OR TWO
MAIN PROJECTS OR THEY'RE
DIVERTING STRAIGHT FROM A
STREAM. AND THEN HAVE A WATER
RIGHT- THAT WE'VE WE'VE
CURTAILED AND SO THAT I KNOW
THAT IS A CHALLENGE FOR SOME
YOU KNOW THAT THAT THEY MAY
HAVE A WATER RIGHT THEY MAY BE
DIVERTED THAT IS NOW CUT OFF
AND IN A YEAR LIKE THIS. THE
CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT ON FOR
SOME OF ITS ITS CONTRACTORS
THERE AT 0% ALLOCATION- THOSE
ISSUES OF THE PRICE OF THAT
CONTRACT WATER WITH THOSE
PROJECTS. THEIR THERE LONG
TERM- YEP ABILITY TO DELIVER
THOSE AMOUNTS KNOW WHAT IT
MEANS FOR THAT THE CONTRACTORS
ON THIS PROJECT SO THAT I CAN
TRUST AND CITIES ARE OFTEN
TIMES- IS AN ISSUE UNLESS THE
BOARD'S PURVIEW THOUGH- BUT IT
IS SOMETHING THAT WE- ARE ARE
AWARE OF AND- AND- IS PART OF
THIS. DISCUSSION I READ LARGE
AROUND HOW BEST WE ARE MANAGING
OUR WATERS- BUT JUST IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT THE ACTIVITIES OR
THE ACTION OF THE BOARD AGREED
TELLING. WATER RIGHTS- IS
TANGENTIALLY CONNECTED TO THAT
THE ISSUES ARE BROUGHT UP WHEN
IT COMES TO. GROWERS PAYING FOR
WATER NOT RECEIVING IT THROUGH
THERE THERE THERE'S BETTER- THE
PROJECTS- AND YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE CERTAINLY AWARE OF AND
WORKING WITH ONE ANOTHER IN
THAT SPACE AND- A LOT OF THAT
IS WITH THE PROJECT MANAGERS AT
THE CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT IN
THE STATE WATER PROJECT WORK.
SOME OF THOSE OTHER LOCAL
PROJECTS ARE HAVING A DIFFICULT
TIME. WITH CERTAINTY IN
DELIVERY AND THIS TIME OF
CLIMATE CHANGE IN CRISIS. THANK
YOU SIR AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I JUST HAVE TWO MORE QUESTIONS
SO PLEASE BEAR WITH ME. SO
THERE'S A NEW BIOLOGICAL
OPINION OUT THERE- THAT CAME
OUT A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO- A-
ON OUTFLOWS THAT WOULD GENERATE
MORE RESEARCH MORE. RESOURCES
IN WATER RESOURCES TO THAT
GROUND I GUESS STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DO. IT REGARDLESS OF
WHERE IT WENT ON BUT IT WOULD
GIVE US TRANCE. WHY AND WHAT'S
YOUR ON THE NEW TO PILOT
OPINION CAME OUT A COUPLE OF
YOUR AGO AND IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT'S GOING TO BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION. OR NOT I GUESS.
ARE TIED TO WHAT IS KNOWN AS
THE ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT AND
IT'S A IT'S A FEDERAL. ACT
THAT. PUTS LIMITS ON. FEDERAL
ACTIONS AND PROJECTS IN HERE
IMPORTANTLY THE CENTRAL VALLEY
PROJECT AND SO THOSE BIOLOGICAL
OPINIONS DICTATED AND WERE
FIRST DEVELOPED- YOU KNOW WELL
THAT. DEPENDING ON WHICH
BIOLOGICAL OPINION BUT- IN IN
THE LATE AT 200-020-0072
THOUSAND EIGHT. WAS WHEN. ONE
OF THE REAL BIOLOGICAL OBJECTS
FOR CAME IN WERE PUT INTO PLACE
THE REPLACED AS HE SAID. TWO
YEARS AGO- AND DURING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION NOW AS I
UNDERSTAND IT THERE ARE
DISCUSSIONS GOING ON WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. I'M NOT
PERSONALLY PRIVY TO THOSE BUT I
KNOW THAT THEY ARE GOING ON.
AND REGARDING WHAT TO DO
REGARDING THEIR LAWSUIT THAT
THE STATE ENDED UP. TRIGGERING
LAST YEAR- WHEN THOSE
BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS WENT INTO-
WHEN INTO A FACT AND THE
DISAGREEMENT THAT THE STATE
HAD. ON THEM- SO- ALL THAT TO
SAY THAT I BELIEVE THOSE
BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS FROM TWO
YEARS AGO ARE STILL. UP FOR
DISCUSSION CURRENTLY MY
OPINIONS ON THE MARK. IN THEIR-
FEDERAL THERE AND ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT I'M REALLY FOCUSED
ACTUALLY ON MAKING SURE THAT
OUR WATER QUALITY CONTROL PLAN
UPDATE. IS UPDATED I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT IS ONE-
STANDARD IS AN EMERGENCY ROOM
APPROACH TO OUR CHALLENGES. WE
NEED REALLY- A WHOLE OF SYSTEM
WATER SHED WHY. APPROACH TO THE
CHALLENGES THAT OUR SPECIES AND
ECOSYSTEMS ARE FACING. BECAUSE
IT'S AN OVER OVER FOCUSING ON
JUST WHAT THE PROJECTS ARE
DOING AT THE PUMPS- THAT IS IN
PART. WHY WEEK WE NEED TO AND
WE HAVEN'T HAD AS MUCH PROGRESS
I FEEL IN THE REST OF THE WATER
SENSE THAT WE NEED AND SO LOOK
FORWARD TO. TEACHING US ALL
TOGETHER IN A WAY THAT MAKES
MOST SENSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IN THE LAST QUESTION I HAVE
JUST- ACTUALLY- TALES TO WHAT
YOU SAID ABOUT THE YOU KNOW THE
WHOLE OF THE WATER SYSTEM
ITSELF. AND THE LAST. QUESTION
I HAVE IS THERE IS THERE IS
SAM. AS WE WATER S. WATER. TO
IN THIS VALLEY THEY A LOT OF
INTO. THROUGHOUT STATE HAVE
GUARD. A NEW TECHNOLOGY I KNOW
YOU'RE AVAILABLE YOU'RE
FAMILIAR WITH THE QUEEN THE
WATER PROJECT- WHERE THEY'VE
TAKEN PRODUCE WATER BLENDED IN
MADE ACT WATER. WHICH IS- MEETS
THE WATER BOARD'S STANDARDS AND
THEN THERE'S- THERE'S- OTHER
WATER THAT'S BEEN PRODUCED
WATER THAT'S BEEN APPROVED BY
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD. THAT IT'S KIND
OF I GUESS THE BEST WAY TO
EXPLAIN IT IT'S NOT A REVERSE
OSMOSIS SYSTEM BUT IT'S LIKE
THAT. IT ACTUALLY GOES INTO
MINES ALL THE MINERALS THAT ARE
IN THE WATER. OF BORON AND
THINGS LIKE THAT- TO REMOVE IT
M. AND THEN HAVE THE WATER THAT
EXCEEDS THE STANDARDS- FROM
STATE WATER BOARD. THERE'S A
LOT OF NEW TECHNOLOGY OUT THERE
IS ARE YOU OR YOUR TEAM OR DO
YOU HAVE SOMEBODY ON YOUR TEAM.
AND HAVING PEOPLE TALK WITH
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE CREATING.
I WANNA SAY NEW WATER IT'S NEW
WATER NEW USABLE WATER I GUESS.
SO IS THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU
GUYS PURSUE- SO THAT WE CAN
LOOK AT YOU KNOW PROVIDING NEW
WATER- FOR THE GOOD OF
EVERYBODY IN CALIFORNIA OR IS
THAT. SOMETHING THAT YOU
HAVEN'T THOUGHT ABOUT YET.
THANK YOU HEY IT HAS BEEN
SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN AT
LEAST FOR ME VERY TOP OF MIND.
WE DON'T HAVE A DEDICATED
INNOVATION UNIT OR- TEAM IF YOU
WELL THAT IS JUST FOCUSED ON
TECHNOLOGIES BUT OUR DIVISION
OF DRINKING WATER. IT IS THE
REGULATORY ARM THAT WOULD
APPROVE ANYTHING THAT ANY NEW
TECHNOLOGIES ANYTHING NEW THAT
COMES ON. THAT IS TRYING TO
MEET STANDARDS AND OF DELIVER
DRINKING WATER ANY SYSTEM THAT.
WOULD LIKE TO SERVE INNOVATOR
OR HAVE SOMETHING IMPROVE WOULD
GO THROUGH THE DIVISION OF
DRINKING WATER. I HAVE HAD.
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR OUR-
DIVISION OF DRINKING WATER HAD
TERRAPLANE MESSED. AROUND HOW
WE CONTINUE TO INCENTIVIZE TO
YOUR POINT. NEW TECHNOLOGIES
AND CONTINUE TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE INNOVATING IN THE SPACE
OF DELIVERY OF CLEAN WATER. AND
WASTE AND HOPEFULLY BRING DOWN
THE COST- AND YES YOU KNOW
REVERSE OSMOSIS IS OUT THERE
IT'S A- TRIED AND TRUE. BUT IT
IS ENERGY INTENSIVE IT IS COST
INTENSIVE IN SHAREPOINT. THERE
ARE. I THINK INNOVATIONS. BEING
BEING PULLED TOGETHER. IT WITH
PACE IF LIKE LEAST BEEN READING
AND TRYING TO KEEP ON TOP OF
THE LITERATURE. THE QUESTION IS
HOW HOW DOES THAT BECOME
IMPLEMENTABLE HOW DOES IT
BECOME SOMETHING THAT'S
APPROVED. AND REGULATORY REALLY
ABLE TO BE INCORPORATED FOR OUR
OUR DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS AND-
IT'S A GOOD QUESTION WE DON'T
LIKE I SAID AS I UNDERSTAND.
HAVE RULED DEDICATED UNIT TO
THAT BUT IT IS WITHIN OUR
PURVIEW AND IT'S BEEN A TOPIC
OF DISCUSSION AT THE BOARD SO I
APPRECIATE THAT. WELL THANK YOU
SIR AND THANK YOU AGAIN NUMBER
ONE FOR AND YOUR HELP WITH- MY
DISTRICT PERSONALLY AND ALWAYS
BEING AVAILABLE. THANK YOU FOR
ANSWERING ALL MY QUESTIONS
TODAY AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING YOU AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU IN THE
FUTURE ON THIS VERY- IMPACTFUL
SUBJECT MATTER THAT AFFECTS ALL
OF US. THANK YOU SENATOR. THANK
YOU SENATOR GROW. OUR SENATOR
COMELEC WITH. THANK YOU MADAM
PRO TEMP. AND IT'S A GOOD TO
SEE YOU AGAIN- I. WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK YESTERDAY
AND- INCREDIBLY- EXCITED ABOUT
THE DISAPPOINTMENT IN I DO
BELIEVE THAT YOU WILL BE
CONFIRMED AND- BELIEVE EVEN
MORE THAT YOU ARE OF THE RIGHT
PERSON AT THIS TIME- TO A- STEP
BACK INTO THIS POSITION. I HAVE
TO SAY IT'S- KIND OF EERIE YOU
KNOW WE'RE HAVING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT. WATER AND
DROUGHT AND RELIABILITY- WHILE
VERY CLOSE TO US. YOU KNOW
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA BURNING
DOWN. AND I CAN ACTUALLY SMELL
IT YOU KNOW IN THIS ROOM AND OF
COURSE THE THING THAT WILL STOP
IT IS WATER- WHICH SEEMS TO BE
A MORE AND MORE FINITE
RESOURCE- AS I MENTIONED TO YOU
YOU KNOW ONE OF MY FAVORITE
MOVIES IS CHINATOWN WHICH
REALLY TALKS ABOUT. THE
IMPORTANCE. OF WATER- AND THE
COMPLEXITIES OF IT- SO I DO ACT
COME FROM LA- I KNOW FOLKS
THINK ALL KIND OF THINGS ABOUT
LOS ANGELES THERE WAS AN
ARTICLE- THAT WAS REFERENCED.
THAT THAT REFERENCE DELAY WHEN
IT TALKED ABOUT MENDOCINO NOT
HAVING ANYMORE WATER THAT
TALKED ABOUT YOU KNOW OUR
STRATEGY AND OUR MUSCLE. IN
TERMS OF- HOW WE'RE ABLE TO
CONSERVE- BUT IT WE ALSO HAVE
VERY SMALL WATER DISTRICTS-
THAT STRUGGLE- AS DO OTHER
SMALLER DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
STATE WHEN IT COMES TO OUT
WATER RELIABILITY. AND CLEAN
WATER SO- AND I ACTUALLY HAD
THE GOOD FORTUNE OF DOING A
COUPLE OF TOURS. TO VISIT SOME
OF THE SMALLER WATER DISTRICTS-
OUTSIDE OF MY DISTRICT BUT A.
J. SENT TO IT- THAT TALKED
ABOUT YOU KNOW. HI RAPES BROWN
WATER COMING OUT OF THE TAP
SOMETIMES NOT HAVING ANY WATER
WHICH YOU DON'T REALLY THINK
ABOUT WHEN YOU THINK ABOT
FOLKS LIVING IN THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES. SO JUST WANTED TO
HEAR FROM YOU YOUR THOUGHTS ON
WHAT ASSISTANCE- THE BOARD CAN
PROVIDE FOR SMALLER WATER
DISTRICTS AND MUNICIPALITIES.
IN THEIR PURSUIT OF CLEAN WATER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER FOR
YOUR REMARKS AND IT ISN'T LOST
ON ME EITHER- CAN SMELL SMELL
SMOKE AND I DON'T KNOW THAT IT
MANY COMMUNITIES ARE ARE BEING
HARMED AND LIVES- BEING TOUCHED
AND AN ARMED HERE AND- AT SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT FOR THAT IT
KNOWLEDGE MEANT. WHEN IT COMES
TO THE THAT SMALL SYSTEMS IN
THE STATE YOU KNOW WE HAVE THE
STATE BOARD I BELIEVE IN WITH
SOMEWHERE AROUND OVER THREE
THOUSAND. I SYSTEMS THAT WE
OVERSEE AND THE STATE AND SOME
OF THEM ARE YOU KNOW OUR OUR
LARGE URBAN AGENCIES AND YOUR
POINT. TOO MANY ARE SMALL
STRUGGLING SYSTEMS. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HELP US
BUILD OUT MANY OF OUR SYSTEMS.
I HAD IT WAS WITH GREAT FEDERAL
INVESTMENT SUBSIDY AND SUPPORT
THAT OUR WASTE WATER AND
DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS AFTER
THE PASSAGE OF THE CLEAN WATER
ACT AND- SAFE DRINKING WATER
ACT- WERE WERE WERE BUILT OUT.
AND THAT IT WAS REALLY IN THE
EIGHTIES AND THE START OF THE
EIGHTIES THIS- THIS THIS
PROGRESSION FROM INVESTMENT.
FROM ON THE FEDERAL SIDE AND
INSTEAD OF SHIFTING TO. LOCAL
REPAIRS AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES
AND IT'S OBVIOUS THAT WE ACT
YOU EITHER AND THAT THE
COMMUNITY OF SIZE TO BE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN. AND CONTINUE DELIVER
AND REINVEST IN AND OUR OUR
BEER DRINKING WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CONTINUE TO
MAINTAIN. A LEVEL OF SERVICE OR
NOT. AND WE HAVE TOO MANY
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE IN THE OR
NOT CATEGORY IN FACT THE STATE
WATER BOARD RECENTLY CONDUCTED
A NEEDS ASSESSMENT. IT'S NOW A
YEARLY JUST ONGOING ASSESSMENT
OF AN UNDERSTANDING OF THE
NEEDS OF OUR SYSTEMS. IT
INCLUDED ALL OF OUR DOMESTIC
WELLS IN THE STATE ALL STATES
MALLS MEETING THEIR UNDER
FIFTEEN CONNECTIONS. AND THEN
THOSE THAT ARE UNDER THIRTY
THREE HUNDRED CONNECTIONS AND
WHAT WE FOUND WERE WELL OVER
SIX HUNDRED SYSTEMS THAT WERE
AT RISK. WE WOULD TERM AT RISK
OFF OF A NUMBER OF FACTORS AND
METHODOLOGIES I ENCOURAGE
EVERYONE TO TAKE  LOOK AT THAT
DOCUMENT IT IS. AN INCREDIBLE-
FIRST I ROLLED. DIVE INTO SEEN
OUR- DATA INFORMATION IS SOLD
TEMP. PART OF THIS RISK.
BECAUSE IF WE KNOW THE STATUS
OF THE SYSTEM WE DON'T KNOW
THAT THEY'RE AT RISK FOR
FAILING AND WE DON'T. GET TO
THEM BEFORE THEY FAIL WE HAVE A
SYSTEM IN PLACE IT IS IT IS
REACTIONARY TO THIS THIS CRISIS
AND THIS CHALLENGE. AS OPPOSED
TO MAKING ACCORDING FOR THE
INVESTMENTS WE NEED. SO WE'RE
FORTUNATE TO HAVE THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE FUND THAT'S THE
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR THAT THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. PROVIDED THE STATE
BOARD TO HELP START TO CLOSE
THIS GAP TO SPEND IT ON
OPERATION AND MAINTENANCE. TO
HAVE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
BECAUSE WHAT WE'VE SEEN AND I
THINK I. MAY HAVE MADE THIS
POINT- BEFORE IT IS JUST THAT
WE- YOU HAVE THAT THE PROGRAMS
THAT WE HAVE. USUALLY BEST
SERVE THOSE LARGER SYSTEMS AND
IT'S THE SMALLER SYSTEMS THAT
NEED MORE THESE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE DOLLARS. EVEN GOT A
PROJECT TO CONSTRUCTION THEY
GOT A TO A POINT WHERE THEY CAN
RECEIVE YOU KNOW PART OF THE
ONE POINT THREE BILLION THAT WE
JUST RECENTLY. RECEIVED THE
STATE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR TO INVESTING CAPITAL
SO. I FEEL WE HAVE A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY HERE TRULY IS A
GENERATIONAL OPPORTUNITY. TO
REVERSE WHAT IS THIS TREND OF
SMALL FAILING SYSTEMS. AND
INSTEAD ENSURE THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES I HAVE ACCESS TO
CLEAN AND SAFE WATER HERE INTO
THE FUTURE AND UNDERSTAND. IT
IT'S ALMOST A DIFFERENT SERVICE
MODEL IT'S A DIFFERENT PROGRAM
ALL TOGETHER WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
OUR FOR SMALLER. SYSTEMS THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
GO TO. THE USUAL YOU KNOW
PROGRAMS LIKE THE STATE
REVOLVING FUND OR. IS OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT- THE FEDERAL.
HASN'T REALLY KEPT UP IN THE-
ON IN AS MANY THAT. SYSTEMS
COMMUNITY THROUGHOUT THE NATION
AND IN THE STATE HAVE BEGUN TO
FALL TO THE CRACKS AND THAT'S
WHERE. WE CAN JUST SO PROUD OF
THE WORK THE STATE HAS DONE.
WITH THE SECOND AFFORDABLE FUN
WITH THE SAFER PROGRAM. TO BE
ABLE TO REALLY REVERSES KIND.
WELL THANK YOU FOR THAT IT
SEEMS LIKE YOU YOU HAVE A
VISION FOR HOW THE STATE CAN
BEGIN TO BALANCE- THE NEEDS AND
THE CHALLENGES. OF THE HAVE
NOTS- VERSUS THE HABS. AND
SOMETIMES HOW YOU DEFINE HAES
AND HAVE NOTS MAY BE VERY
DIFFERENT BUT I THINK WE HAVE
TO BE REALLY. FAIR AND JUST
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
HAVES AND THE HAVE NOTS. AS IT
RELATES TO WATER WHICH IS
INCREDIBLY- CRITICAL. RESOURCE
YOU KNOW I ALWAYS WONDER LIKE
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU KNOW
ARMAGEDDON HITS ARE WE GOING TO
pWATER WORLD AND IT SEEMS LIKE
WE'RE MOVING TOWARDS MAD MAX
WHICH IS. INCREDIBLY SCARY-
THERE'S ALWAYS THIS TENSION
BETWEEN. WATER RELIABILITY AND
PROTECTING THE ENVIRONMENT AND
IT'S SOMETHING THAT I THINK
ABOUT IN LOS ANGELES. I KNOW
IT'S ALSO SOMETHING THAT IS
THOUGHT ABOUT- IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. AS WELL- AND IN
NORTHERN PARTS OF CALIFORNIA.
AND I KNOW THAT THE BOARD HAS
UNDERTAKEN. YOU KNOW MANY
ACTIONS TO PROTECT FISHERIES
AND THE ENVIRONMENT- WE DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF FISHERIES IN LOS
ANGELES SO I AM. INSTEAD OF
HONING FOR A FRIEND I'M ASKING
FOR A FRIEND- AND IMPROVED
CONDITIONS FOR FISH AND
WILDLIFE RESTORATION ARE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT GOALS- I
KNOW WITH CLIMATE CHANGE WE
EXPECT TO SEE. EVEN MORE
FREQUENT AND LONGER LASTING
DRAFTS I FEEL LIKE WE SORT OF
ONCE WE AND ONE WERE IN ANOTHER
ONE. AND SO WANTED TO KNOW AND-
IF YOU SUPPORT VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS- AS A WAY TO BALANCE
THE NEEDS OF THE ENVIRONMENT
AND WATER SUPPLY RELIABILITY.
YES YEAH I MEAN WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE ENORMITY OF THE WORK AND
TASK THAT WE ALL HAVE IN OUR
WATERSHEDS IF YOU. TO ADDRESS
THE CLIMATE CRISIS TO ENSURE
THAT OUR COMMUNITIES CAN CAN
THRIVE INTO THE FUTURE HERE
KNOWING- THE CHALLENGES AT WORK
WE'RE HEARING TRACING. IT
REQUIRES LOCALS WITH LOCAL
LEADERSHIP AND EXPERTISE TO OWN
THIS CHALLENGE AND COME TO THE
STATE WITH WITH. WITH WORK WITH
AGREEMENT ON ON HOW BEST TO
MOVE FORWARD. BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ALWAYS KNOW THAT
YOU KNOW VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS
NEED TO HAVE SOMETHING TO AIM
TOWARD. AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE ALSO SET THE BAR TO WHICH
AGREEMENTS MEET AND THEN WE CAN
SAY WITH CERTAINTY THAT YES
THIS VOLUNTARY EFFORT IS
PROTECTED. ISN'T HIS ENSURING
THIS COMMON OUTCOME THAT WE ARE
ALL DESIRING. I FEEL SOMETIMES
THERE'S JUST SOMETIMES A FALSE
DICHOTOMY THAT'S THAT'S PLACED
BEFORE WHAT'S REGULATORY
WORKING WITH A VOLUNTARY ACTION
AND I THINK THAT IT'S REALLY A
CONTINUAL. EFFORT BETWEEN THE
TWO AND ALL TOGETHER IT'S ABOUT
THE OUTCOMES IT'S ABOUT THE
COMMON OUTCOMES THAT I THINK WE
ALL SEE AND WANT FOR A
COMMUNITIES. WHICH IS ACCESS TO
CLEAN WATER WHICH IS CONTINUED
ECONOMIC SUCCESS AND VIABILITY
AND TO PROVIDE. A COMMON A GOOD
FOR US ALL AND NOT ALLOW JUST
YOU KNOW. THE NEEDS AND DESIRES
OF A FEW TO- TO TAKE UP MOST OF
THE DECISION MAKING STATES. AND
SO- SO I AM VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT OF ALL INTERIOR
PAYMENTS ARE OUR BOARD HAS BEEN
CONSISTENT ABOUT THEM AND
THEY'RE USUALLY DISCUSSED IN
THE CONTEXT OF OUR UPDATE OF
THE WATER QUALITY CONTROL PLAN
UPDATE- BUT IT IT INCLUDES
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS AND- WATER
RATES CURTAILMENT. JUST
YESTERDAY AND DAY BEFORE WE'RE
HAVING DISCUSSION- IN- AND OUR
RETIREMENTS FOR THIS TIME
SHASTA RIVER AND LEAVING OPEN.
THE ABILITY FOR VOLUNTEER
AGREEMENT IT'S TO COME TO AT
THE LOW LEVEL. BUT IMPORTANTLY
IT'S ALL ON ON COM OUTCOMES.
AND MEASURABLE COMMON THAT
DON'T HAVE AMONGST THE OTHER.
THANK YOU FOR THE- YOU KNOW I
THAT. AS I HAVE TAKEN A COUPLE
OF WATER TOWARDS MYSELF IT
ALWAYS SEEMS LIKE THE QUESTIONS
ARE. DO YOU PROVIDE WATER OR DO
YOU PROTECT THE FTSE THE SMELT
YOU KNOW- AND I WONDER HOW DO
WE GET TO A PLACE WHERE WE CAN
SAY YES TO BOTH- AND JUST KIND
OF WANTED TO KNOW YOUR THOUGHTS
ON ACTIONS THAT CAN BE TAKEN
TO. AID BOTH- WHICH IS PROBABLY
EXPANDING ON THE FIRST QUESTION
I ASK BUT YOU KNOW EIGHT
CONTINUING TO DO THINGS THAT
WILL PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT
WHILE ALSO HELPING FOLKS
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
WATER RELIABILITY- AND THE
CRITICAL ILLNESS OF MAKING SURE
THAT THAT'S AVAILABLE ON TO
EVERYONE ACROSS THE STATE- DO
YOU DID I MEAN DO YOU FEEL THAT
TENSION- DO YOU FEEL LIKE THEIR
PATHWAYS THROUGH THIS. I
DEFINITELY FEEL THAT TENSION-
AND YOU KNOW I DO FEEL THERE
ARE PATHWAYS THROUGH IT BUT I
THINK IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE
ROSS US ALL TO BE JUST BE. VERY
HONEST WITH THE CHALLENGES THAT
WE'RE FACING. AND TO REALLY
RECOGNIZE THAT WERE RECONCILING
A SYSTEM THAT WE'VE ALL
INHERITED. WE HAVE TWENTY FOUR
IN NINETEEN CENTURY LAWS
TWENTIETH CENTURY
INFRASTRUCTURE IN TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY CHALLENGES. AND THE
REALITY IS THAT WE BUILT OUT SO
MUCH OF WHAT WE HAVE. FOR A
CLIMATE THAT NO LONGER EXISTS
SIMPLY NO LONGER EXISTS. AND
RECONCILING THAT FACT
RECONCILING THESE INVESTMENTS
AND ENSURING THAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WE HAVE NOW CAN
START TO. MOVE TOWARD THE
REALITY OF. A CALIFORNIA WITH
THE REDUCED IMPACT. INCREASING
AND LONGER DROUGHTS FLASH
FLOODS RISING SEA NEEDS. WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO BE ABLE TO REALLY
THINK OCT HERE AND RECOGNIZE
THAT THE DECISIONS WE'RE MAKING
NOW ARE SENDING US ON A PATH
FOR THE NEXT FIFTY YEARS. AND
THAT WE NEED TO ACT JUST BE
HONEST WITH OURSELVES WITH THE
ENORMITY OF THE CHALLENGES WE
FACE. AND I FEEL NOW I'LL JUST
SAY CANDIDLY THAT OFTENTIMES
SOME ARE STILL CLINGING TO THE
STATUS QUO. THAT AGAIN
REGRETTABLY IS NO LONGER HERE.
OUR CLIMATE HAS CHANGED OUR
WATER SYSTEMS WERE BUILT FOR A
DIFFERENT CENTURY IN A
DIFFERENT TIME AND WE'RE GONNA
NEED TO SEE A REAL
GENERATIONAL. SHIFT IN OUR
THINKING LET ALONE A
GENERATIONAL REINVESTMENT. IN
THE SYSTEMS THEMSELVES. AMEN
BROTHER- YOU KNOW I'LL QUESTION
WHICH WE TALKED ABOUT WHEN WE
MET BUT I JUST WANT TO GIVE YOU
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THIS
WITH THE REST OF THE COMMITTEE
BUT WE TALKED ABOUT YOU KNOW
YOU BEING CHAIR- AND LEADERSHIP
AS CHAIR AND PART OF THE ROLE
AS A CHAIR IS ALSO TO INSPIRE
AND EMPOWER STAFF AND THE WORK
THAT YOU ALL YOU ARE- OF
FACILITATING AND LEADING
INTERNALLY AROUND REAL
DISCUSSIONS- WITH A VERY
DIVERSE STAFF- WITH THE REALITY
THAT WATER IS A HUMAN RIGHT-
ANNA KNOWLEDGE IN SOME OF THE
YOU KNOW EMAIL REPLY ALL. GAUGE
THAT WAS GOING ON- AT THE BOARD
SO JUST WANTED TO LET YOU- TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE WORK
THAT YOU ARE HELPING TO LEAD
INTERNALLY WITH YOUR STAFF-
AROUND THIS KIND OF WATER
JUSTICE AND MAKING SURE THAT
ALL VOICES ARE SEEN AND HEARD
AN ELEVATED IN THIS DISCUSSION
AROUND- WATER RIGHTS JUSTICE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR YOU
KNOW I CAN'T HELP BUT LOOK
AROUND CERTAINLY AND THE
CLIMATE CRISIS YOU KNOW WE'RE
FEELING IT- IT'S HERE BUT SO
ARE THE RACIAL INEQUALITY SAID
THAT WE SEE AND WE CAN WE- NEED
TO ACKNOWLEDGE. AND BY SENIOR
TECHNOLOGY AND TRY TO TRY TO.
UNDERSTAND AND AN ADDRESS. YOU
KNOW HI IT I'LL JUST SAY THAT.
RACE ISN'T AN EASY THING TO
TALK ABOUT RACIAL INEQUALITIES
AND INEQUITY IS NOT A SIMPLE
DISCUSSION FOR ANYONE FOR
MYSELF- I KNOW I CARRY MY OWN
BIAS SEES LIFE I AM. I AM PROUD
OF MYSELF IN PERFECT BUT ALSO
THAT AS GOVERNMENT INSTITUTIONS
IT'S NOT AN EASY THING CUT
UNDERTAKEN DISCUSSION AROUND
RACIAL INEQUALITY. BUT I THINK
THAT NOT UNLIKE CLIMATE CHANGE
AND THE OBVIOUSNESS OF THE
LANDS FROM WHICH IMPACTS ALL OF
OUR WORK AND THEN THE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND IT CUT. TO FIGURE IT
OUT TO THEN NAVIGATE AND MANAGE
THROUGH IT SO TOO I FEEL ARE
THE CHALLENGES OF THE RACIAL
INEQUITIES AND INEQUALITIES
THAT WE FIND OURSELVES WITH.
AND SO THE BOARD HAS
UNDERTAKEN- RACIAL EQUITY-
INITIATIVE AND PART OF THAT IS
THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
RESOLUTION- AND IMPORTANTLY
IT'S TAKEN US A YEAR TO
ACTUALLY DRAFT IT AND BECAUSE
WE'VE NEEDED TO OURSELVES HAVE
CONVERSATIONS. ABOUT THE ISSUE
AND TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE
IS AN ISSUE INTO IT INTO ALSO.
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT- SOME MAY NOT
SEE IT EMISSIONS SOME HAVE HAVE
SAID THAT BY. RACE OR RACIAL
INEQUALITY. IF IT IS ITSELF
CREATING- WHICH IS INTERESTING.
BUT I THINK THAT WHAT WE WHAT
WE CAN DO- IS TO HAVE A
DISCUSSION BE MINDFUL THAT
RACIAL INEQUITY INEQUALITY IS.
SUCH A HUGE IMPACT WHEN WE LOOK
AT WHEN YOU LOOK AT ACCESS TO
CLEAN WATER ACCESS TO
SANITATION. AND THAT WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND. THAT IN ORDER TO
NOT PERPETUATE. THE
INEQUALITIES THAT WE SEE AND
HOPEFULLY HELP CONTRIBUTE TO.
THE EQUITY TO THE SORTS OF
COMMUNITIES THAT THAT WE WANT
TO SEE I THINK. IT'S NOT LOST
ON ME I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT.
THAT YOU LOOK BACK FIFTY YEARS
AGO WHEN THE BOARD ITSELF WAS
WAS WAS CREATED UNDER QUARTER
CULLEN. YOU LOOK AT THE CLEAN
WATER ACT YOU LOOK AT THE SAFE
DRINKING WATER ACT. THOSE WERE
ALSO AND THE DANGER SPECIES ACT
THESE YOU KNOW THESE THESE
REALLY BIG ARE. INCREDIBLE THIS
IS A LEGISLATION THAT REALLY
SHIFTED THE WAY THAT WE SEE AND
ACKNOWLEDGE OUR CHALLENGES. BUT
THOSE TWO WERE WERE HAPPENING
AT TEN THE CIVIL RIGHTS ACT.
IMPORTANTLY WHAT IS WITH OUR
DISCUSSION AND THAT RACIAL AND
INEQUALITY SEGREGATION SO MUCH
OF. THE THINGS THAT WE THOUGHT
WERE WERE LEFT IN THE PAST ARE
STILL A CHALLENGE NOT UNLIKE
THE ENVIRONMENTAL CHALLENGES WE
SEE TODAY. SO I THINK IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO. AS AS
ALL GENERATIONS DUE TO RECOMMIT
OURSELVES. TO WHAT WAS THEN A
REVOLUTION AROUND THE WAY WE'VE
BUTTE AND STARK COMMUNITIES
ABOUT I WAS THE BENEFICIARY OF.
BEING BORN IN EIGHTY TWO BEING
A MILLENNIAL HERE I PROMISE I
THOUGHT I TOO WAS PART OF
ALREADY A SOCIETY THAT. WAS
QUOTE UNQUOTE WAISTLINE OR THAT
SOMEHOW REYES WASN'T
DETERMINATIVE OUTCOMES. BUT I
THINK THAT WE'RE ALL CLEARLY
HERE AND CLEAR EYED
UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT'S NOT
THE CASE. AND THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS IT BOTTOM LIKE. CLIMATE
CHANGE IN IN IN THE SERIOUSNESS
OF THE CHALLENGE. THAT IT IS
BUT ALSO IN RECOGNIZE ZING AT
THAT APPROVING. SO MUCH OUR
WORK IT CAN BE. TO EVEN CAN
DOWN. AND WHY WE NEED TO BE
SPECIFIC AND INTENTIONAL WITH
OUR WORK AND SO I'M CREDIT WE
PROUD OF OUR- OUR OUR AGENCY IN
THE WORK THAT THEY'VE BEEN
DOING. APPARENTLY THE WATER
SECTOR WRIT LARGE WHICH IS
COMMON IN MANY WAYS EMBRACE
THIS EFFORT AS WELL AND I
THANK. MANY OF THE LEADERS OUT
THERE TO BUT THE COURAGE AND-
THE BRAVERY TO TACKLE A NOT
EASY DISCUSSION. BUT SUCH A
CRITICAL ONE FOR NOT GOING TO
PERPETUATE AND HAVE COMMUNITIES
THAT. HAVE THESE GREAT
INEQUITIES INCLUDING THE ONE
THAT I MYSELF GREW UP IN THE
EASTERN PROTONMAIL. THANK YOU-
SO I. I APPRECIATE YOUR
BACKGROUND- YOUR PHYSICAL
BACKGROUND BECAUSE I LIKE
LOOKING AT THOSE IMAGES. I
APPRECIATE YOUR HONESTY-
BECAUSE- YOU CAN TELL WHEN
SOMEONE IS REALLY TELLING YOU
THE TRUTH- ABOUT THEIR PLANS
AND WHAT THEY SEE AND THEIR
VISION. AND IT REALLY COMES OUT
WITH YOU I APPRECIATE THAT
GREATLY- AND I ALSO GREATLY
APPRECIATE YOUR DESIRE TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE- AND WILL BE
VERY HAPPY- TO SUPPORT. YOUR
CONFIRMATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR- WELL I WOULD TO
ADD ON. TO THE CONVERSATION I
APPRECIATE THE- QUESTIONS AND
TOPICS AT ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE BROUGHT UP HERE TODAY- IF
YOU LOOK AROUND YOU SEE WE
REPRESENT- ALL OF US. VERY
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES I THINK
THE VICE CHAIR AND I HAVE MORE
OF A SIMILAR. STORY B. AND FROM
A PART OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
NOT LOS ANGELES- AS IT RELATES
TO ISSUES OF- OF DESALINATION.
YEAH THE PURE WATER A PROJECT
THAT WE HAVE IN SAN DIEGO THAT
WERE GONNA CELEBRATE AND
INVESTMENT OF RESOURCES.
TOWARDS ON FRIDAY OF THIS WEEK-
BUT IT'S REALLY INTERESTING-
YOU KNOW WE ALWAYS TALK ABOUT
THE POLITICS OF WATER HAS LESS
TO DO WITH OUR- POLITICAL PARTY
AND MORE TO DO WITH THE
GEOGRAPHY AND THE FORMER CHAIR
OF THE- FORMER SECRETARY SORRY
OF. NATURAL RESOURCES THIS IS A
LED TO A VERY SUBSTANTIVE
DISCUSSION AND SINCE YOUR
RETURN TO CALIFORNIA FROM THE
FROM A PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION
I THINK WE HAVE BENEFITTED A
NUMBER OF US HAVE SAID ON THIS-
RULES COMMITTEE AND- CONFIRM TO
MULTIPLE TIMES AND HAD. MANY
DISCUSSIONS SO HI YOU SHARE MY
COLLEAGUES- INCREDIBLE-
COMPLIMENTS TO YOU IN TERMS OF
YOUR NOT YOUR- ARM THE- THAT WE
HAVE IN YOU. SO ALL OF THE
COMMENTS QUESTIONS BEEN ASKED
AYE AYE YET AGAIN I FIND WITH
ONCE A- QUESTION I YOU KNOW WE
DO. A DE S. B. TWO- FROM OUR
FORMER COLLEAGUE SENATOR MINING.
ON THE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER PROGRAM- AND OF
COURSE SAYS- I DON'T KNOW IF
THIS WAS A COMMUNITY THAT
BENEFITED FROM THAT PARTICULAR
PROGRAM PHOTO SO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM. BAKERSFIELD AND KERN
COUNTY MADE A COMMENT ABOUT
NEEDLES CAN YOU GIVE ME AN IDEA
OF SOME O THE COMMUNITIES THUS
FAR THAT PROGRAM HAS- HAS
HELPED SO FAR- KIND OF WHERE
THEY'RE LOCATED IN AND- IT DID
IT DID THEY NOT HAVE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
BEFORE AND HAVE IT NOW I MEAN
JUST GIVE ME A PICTURE. OF THAT
IF YOU WOULD. THANK YOU.
SENATOR THE WORK OF THE DAY AT
THE DIVISION OF DRINKING WATER
AND SAFER AS FANS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE YOU KNOW I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE PROJECTS UP AND DOWN-
THE STATE AND BUT THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF CONCENTRATED ONES IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY- WHERE. WE
SEE A NUMBER OF AT PARTICULARLY
RULE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND CHALLENGES WITH DRINKING
WATER- YOU KNOW I'M I'M GLAD
AND I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT WE
HAVE PROVIDED ONE OF FOUR
HUNDRED AND NINETY SIX AND
TRUMP. SOLUTIONS SINCE THE
PROGRAM FIRST STARTED HERE AND
THAT INCLUDES ALSO THAN ANOTHER
HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT- PLANNING
ASSISTANCE GRANTS AND THAT'S
TOUCHING OVER TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE- WE'VE
CONSOLIDATED OF I OR WILL HAVE
COMPLETED FORTY SEVEN
CONSOLIDATIONS HERE AND THAT
TIME AS WELL- AND SO- YOU KNOW
PARTICULARLY. YOU KNOW WHAT
COMES TO MIND OUR OUR
COMMUNITIES LIKE EASTERN
COACHELLA VALLEY. WHO HAVE
CONSOLIDATION PROJECTS IN PLACE
TO EXTEND SERVICE TO A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT- AT MOBILE HOME
PARKS THERE AND THEN SIMILARLY
IN LAKE COUNTY THERE HAVE BEEN
A NUMBER OF CONSOLIDATIONS AND
SO WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS THAT.
YOU TRULY WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
LONG TERM FOR THE SMALLER
SYSTEMS A CONSOLIDATION. AND IS
ONE OF OUR OUR STRONGER TOOLS
BECAUSE IT ALLOWS THEM TO
CONNECT TO A MORE STABLE LONGER
TERM SYSTEM AND ALLOW FOR THE
REPAIR BASE THAT WE WILL BE
KNOWS REALLY IMPORTANT TO
MAINTAIN SYSTEMS. INTO THE
FUTURE AND SO WE'RE LOOKING TO
CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE
ACCELERATING THOSE. HERE IN THE
TIME AHEAD AS WELL. THANK YOU
AND THE LAST COMMENT I WOULD
MAKE TWO OF TO A POINT I THINK
THE VICE CHAIR. STARTED TO TALK
ABOUT WHEN WE LOOK AT. TOOLS IN
THE TOOLBOX OF WHICH
DESALINATION IS ONE AN
OBVIOUSLY WORKING THROUGH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES AROUND-
MAKING IT A BETTER JOB. TYPE OF
ODD TOOL- ENVIRONMENTALLY. IN
THIS THE. PARTNER AGENCIES THAT
YOU HAVE TO WORK WHEN THEY'RE-
THAT HAVE TO GO THROUGH. THE
COASTAL. THOUGH WATER QUALITY
CONTROL BOARD AND I'M NOT SURE
WHO ELSE- IS THAT PROCESS
GETTING SMOOTHER ARE YOU GIVE
ME JUST A COUPLE OF SENTENCES
ON. HOW YOU SEE THAT PER YOU
KNOW PROCEEDING AT THIS POINT
BECAUSE I'VE HEARD OBVIOUSLY
WE'LL HEAR THE STORIES WERE
THEY DON'T. GO SO SMOOTHLY BUT
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT. YEAH I
THINK WE I APPRECIATE THAT
SENATOR I HAVE TO SAY I THINK
WE NEED TO GET BETTER AT
BACKWARD NATION UP- MET SOME
MONTHS PROJECTS- PROJECTS IN
SOMETIMES GET LOST IN THAT
PERMIT SHUFFLE IT IS NOT AN
EASY PROCESS- AND I KNOW MY
MIND GOES TO. THINGS LIKE
INFRASTRUCTURE DASHBOARDS THAT
I KNOW WERE DEVELOPED ON THE
FEDERAL SIDE WHEN IT COMES TO
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS IN
ORDER TO ON THEIR SIDE AND
BETTER COORDINATE THAT
PERMITTING ACTIVITY AMONGST
NUMEROUS STATE AGENCIES. SO I
THINK THAT THERE ARE WAYS THAT
WE CAN DEFINITELY BE THINKING
ABOUT HOW WE IMPROVE THOSE- AND
YOU KNOW WHEN IT COMES TO THESE
OTHER JUST SUCH COMPLICATED
PROJECTS THAT YEAH THE END UP.
AT IT HAVING TO GO THROUGH
MULTIPLE AGENCIES AND BETTER
COORDINATING- THOSE PERMITS
AMONGST US I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN REALLY I
THINK ABOUT IN ORDER TO HELP
MAKE SURE THE PROJECTS ARE
BEING DELIVERED YES WHILE BEING
PROTECTIVE. BUT WHILE ALSO.
HAVING SOME SOME BETTER PROCESS
AROUND. THANK YOU HI I WISH YOU
LUCK IN THAT BECAUSE- HERE IN
YEAH I MEAN IT IS NEVER EASY TO
MAKE IT THROUGH. ANY PRIVATE
YOU KNOW PROCESS AND THOSE
PROCESSES ARE THERE FOR A
REASON. BUT AT THE SAME TIME IF
YOU'RE HAVING TO GO THROUGH
MULTIPLE AGENCIES AND ONE
AGENCY GIVES YOU THE GREEN
LIGHT AND ANOTHER ONE
ABSOLUTELY STOPS THE PROJECT.
WE'VE GOT A PROBLEM. AND I
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT OU
OBVIOUSLY HAVE SOME DEGREE OF
PATIENTS FOR- FOR GOING HROUGH
THAT PROCESS I HOPE I HOPE YOU
COME OUT ON THE OTHER SIDE
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
COMMUNITIES ARE GOING TO
BENEFIT FROM THAT- I DON'T HAVE
QUESTIONS I'D I JUST. TRULY
APPRECIATE I AM MORE QUESTIONS
I TRULY APPRECIATE- YOUR
EXPERTISE I FEEL LIKE WE ARE SO
FORTUNATE I IN CALIFORNIA. TO
HAVE DATA. ON THE FUTURE YOU'RE
WELCOME- WE ARE GOING TO GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT A I THINK WE
HAVE FIVE CERTAINLY COVER LOTS
OF BASES AND APPRECIATE SO MUCH
YOUR TIME. AND SO NOW WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WE'RE GOING TO START
RIGHT HERE. IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE I'LL GO BACK TO MY
SCRIPT. I AND I WILL AGAIN PUT
THE NUMBER UP ON THE SCREEN
WITH THE GREAT ASSISTANCE OF
STAFF- THERE IS A TOLL FREE
NUMBER. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO
TWO SIX EIGHT ONE EIGHT NINE.
THAT ACCESS CODE IS UP THERE
TOO TWO EIGHT SEVEN. ALSO IT'S
UP THERE ALSO TWO EIGHT SEVEN
SIX ZERO FIVE NINE. AND WITH
THAT- WE WILL START WITH-
ANYONE HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT WE'LL START
WITH SUPPORT. A SEEING I KNOW
WHAT I'M GOING TO LOOK AT OUR
SECOND ROOM THAT WE ALWAYS HAVE
ROOM ONE TWELVE. AND THERE IS
NO ONE THERE- SO I'M GONNA
INTRODUCE OUR MODERATOR AND SAY
WELCOME AS WE GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE. AND I WILL HAVE
OUR MODERATOR PROF INDIVIDUALS
BUT BEFORE WE START. I WANT TO
REMIND OUR WITNESSES OF THIS-
WHEN WE A WHEN YOU SPEAK PLEASE
PROVIDE YOUR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION IF ANY. YOUR
POSITION ON THE APPOINTMENT AND
ON AGAIN ON BEHALF OF OUR COURT
REPORTER. PLEASE SPEAK SLOWLY
AND CLEARLY WITH THAT MODERATOR
LET ME WELCOME YOU TO OPEN THE
LINES AND- MOVE FORWARD. THANK
YOU. TO EXPRESS YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS APPOINTMENT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. ONCE AGAIN
THAT'S ONE THEN THEY'RE ALL AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AND I'M SURE
WE HAVE SEVERAL LINES IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. FOREGO FIRST
PLANE. THIRTEEN GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS CAITLYN KALO- ON
APPOINTMENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
COAST KEEPER ALLIANCE AND WE
BECAME STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
COMMISSION JOAQUIN ASK ABOUT.
THE STATE WATER BOARD- IN THE
LAST FOUR YEARS I'M VERY
IMPRESSED WITH THE- LOOKING
ENOUGH ABOUT THE PROGRAM- TO BE
VERY MEASURED YOU KNOW FORTY
THINKING LEADER. UP FOR
CALIFORNIA- AND ARE QUITE
FRANKLY ARE VERY PRESSING WATER
CHALLENGES US AGAIN WE SUPPORT-
CHARACTER BELL CONFIRMATION.
AND WELCOME ANOTHER TERM THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER.
BUT OUR NEXT SPEAKERS LINE.
FIFTEEN ONE FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
LIAM TRITON TRITON PRICE ON
BEHALF OF THE WATER FOUNDATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
REAPPOINTMENT JOAQUIN ASKED
ABOUT AS CHAIR THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD. UNDER
MR APPLE BOB LEADERSHIP AT THE
STATE WATER BOARD HAD MADE
IMPORTANT PROGRESS IN
IMPLEMENTING THE HUMAN RIGHT TO
WATER. YESTERDAY THEY RELEASED
THE FIRST TWO HUNDRED MILLION
FOR DRINKING AND WASTEWATER
IMPROVEMENT. LISTENING TO MR AT
THE BALL TODAY IT'S CLEAR HE IS
THE LEADER WE NEED ADMIN
ADVOCATE THE- DROUGHT THE WATER
BOARD HAD TO MAKE VERY
DIFFICULT DECISIONS GIVEN THE
CRITICAL SITUATION BUT THEY
PRIORITIZE PROTECTING THE
PUBLIC TRUST. WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH MR
APPLE BOMB THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THE COURT. THE APPOINTMENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. NINE EIGHTEEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM WE WERE TOP HERE
ON BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO MAYOR
TODD GLORIA IN THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO IN SUPPORT OF
DISAPPOINTMENT. SAN DIEGO IS AT
THE END OF THE STATE'S WATER
PIPE SOMETHING HOMES A CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR BY NO BETTER
THAN ANY. ASKED ABOUT HIS
ALWAYS BEEN RESPONSIVE TO OUR
NEEDS OR QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS.
IT'S KEENLY AWARE OF THE
DIVERSITY OF THE STATE MERION
WATER REGION'S THEIR UNIQUE
CHALLENGES. THERE NEED. IS THAT
OUR CITY A NUMBER OF TIMES AND
WAS AND IS CONTINUING TO BE
ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN HELPING US
FIND SOLUTIONS. WE STRONGLY
ENDORSED HER ASK ABOUT THREE
APPOINTMENT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. BY IN. TWENTY FOUR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
MARK SMITH WITH THE SMITH
POLICY GROUP CALLING TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE EL DORADO WATER
AGENCIES THE GRASSLAND WATER
DISTRICT THE CALIFORNIA
WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE CONFIRMATION AND
BOARD CHAIR ASK ABOUT WE HAVE
FOUND TO BE A THOUGHTFUL AND
DELIBERATE IN PERSON WHO
GENUINELY TAKES INTO ACCOUNT.
THE VARIOUS PERSPECTIVES FROM
ALL SIDES AND STRIVES TO DO
WHAT IS BEST FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR THESE REASONS WE
SUPPORT HIS CONFIRMATION TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THE LINE TWENTY THREE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JENNIFER CLARITY ON THE
CALIFORNIA DIRECTOR FOR CLEAN
WATER ACTION AND I'M SPEAKING
OF TRUMP SUPPORT TODAY FOR THE
REAPPOINTMENT CARE ACT ABOUT
HE'S BEEN A CHAMPION FOR SAFE
DRINKING WATER AND- THEN WHEN
HE WORKED WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO IN THE
DRINKING WATER PROGRAM WITH
THEIR I CAN ONLY SAY THAT THE
PROGRESS. WE'VE MADE AND
PROVIDING SAFE DRINKING WATER
TO COMMUNITIES HAS BEEN
ASTRONOMICAL OVER THE PAST
SEVEN YEARS AND ESPECIALLY THE
PAST FOUR YEARS UNDER HIS
DIRECTION THANK YOU AND I
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S SUPPORT
FORM. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
LINE. TWENTY SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON JEANNIE MINOR ON
BEHALF OF EASTERN MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT AS WELL AS BEING
A MARGARITA WATER DISTRICT I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT AND YOU'RE
AT THE BOTH THE APPOINTMENT- WE
KNOW YOU KNOW THIS IS A
CHALLENGING TIME FOR STATE WHEN
IT COMES TO WATER RESOURCES AND
BELIEVE CHAIR AT THE BALLOT
WELL EQUIPPED TO LEAD US
THROUGH AYE WE ESPECIALLY
APPRECIATE THE ACCEPTABILITY
EXPERTISE IN PROBLEM SOLVING
ORIENTED APPROACH AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH HIM. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
BUYING. SIXTY GOOD AFTERNOON
MICHAEL CLAIBORNE I'M NOT
DIRECTING INTERNET LEADERSHIP
COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND I'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS STRONG SUPPORTER CARE
ASK ABOUT THE DRINKING WATER
AND WASTEWATER CHALLENGES THE
STATE FACES ARE IMMENSE AND
SOLUTIONS ARE URGENTLY NEEDED
ESPECIALLY IN THE FACE THE
WORSENING DROUGHT AND CLIMATE
CHANGE THIS IS DENNIS
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY WATER CONTAMINATION
OVERDRAFT. AND DRY WELLS. WELL
THE THOUGHTFUL DILIGENT AND
MAYBE MOST IMPORTANTLY
ACCESSIBLE AND RESPONSIVE
LEADER OF THE STATE BOARD
DURING THESE CHALLENGING TIMES.
I'D ALSO SAY THAT BY BLOWING
HITO KATIE HE ASKED THAT I CAN
BE THEIR SUPPORT AS WELL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
LINE. TWENTY GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ROGER
DICKINSON FOR THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION HI ECHO
THE OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THE REAPPOINTMENT OF CHAIR
ASKED ABOUT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
KLEIN. FOURTEEN GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS JENNIFER WEST AND
THE MANAGING DIRECTOR OF WATER
REUSE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
SURE ALCOHOL- THE RECYCLED
WATER REGULATORY PROGRAM IS THE
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO DTH- TO THE
WATER BOARD AND I CAN SAY THAT
IT HAS BEEN VERY SUCCESSFULLY
MANAGED UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF
THE WATER BOARD AND SHERMAN
AFTER ABOUT- RECENTLY THEY ARE
STARTING TO BALLOT BEING DIRECT
POTABLE REUSE REGULATIONS WHICH
WILL BE COMPLETE BY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. AND THIS WILL
HELP DEVELOP- OUR CLIMATE- HELP
US RESPOND TO CLIENT AND
DEVELOP- DROUGHT RESISTANT
WATER SUPPLY SO THIS WILL BE
THE FIRST STATEWIDE REGULATIONS
FOR DPR AND ARE PART IN OUR
ENTIRE COUNTRY HELP COUNTY
CALIFORNIA IN A LEADERSHIP
POSITION ON RECYCLED WATER- SO
I VERY MUCH SUPPORT ON BEHALF
OF WHAT EVERY YEAR CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. WINE NINETY NINE.
THANK YOU CHAIR ATKINS AND
MEMBERS CINDY TECH WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES PARKWAY IS PLEASED TO
SUPPORT SENATE CONFIRMATION OF
CHAIR ESCOBAL I JUST MENTION A
COUPLE QUICK THINGS ONE WE
APPRECIATE THE VERY FRANK
CONVERSATIONS THAT WERE ABLE TO
HAVE WITH YOUR SQL WE ALSO
APPRECIATE HIS FEDERAL
EXPERIENCE THAT HE BRINGS TO
THE BOARD THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS. PINE.
TWENTY SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS AT FOR
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY CALLING
IN TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE
CONFIRMATION OF TERROR AFTER
ABOUT TO CONTINUE AS CHAIR OF
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD IS ABOUT THE
LEADER AND MEETING GRATEFUL FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP OVER THE PAST
FOUR YEARS AND A DEDICATED
LEADERSHIP IS NEEDED NOW MORE
THAN PERHAPS EVER BEFORE
CONSIDERING THE CHALLENGES
CALIFORNIA IS CURRENTLY FACING
SOUTHERLY TO WATER AMONG OTHER
MAJOR ISSUES. IN THE BELIEVE HE
DOES DURING EVERY APPOINTMENT
AS CHAIR AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. PINE SEVENTEEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON- CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KYLE JOHN POLICY
DIRECTOR WITH COMMUNITY WATER
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
REAPPOINTMENT AND CONFIRMATION
OF CHAIR OF THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
THEY'VE ALL BEEN A GREAT
PARTNER INFORMING IN
IMPLEMENTING THAT THEY FOR
PROGRAM. AND CONTINUING TO WORK
TO MAKE THE BORDER TRANSPARENT
AND PUBLIC SAFETY ORGANIZATION.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH THEM TO REMIND THE
HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER IN
CALIFORNIA AND FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP SB FACES THE
STARCRAFT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
BLINDING TWENTY EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON TYLER FUNDING ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN COUNCIL
OF ENGINEERING COMPANIES
CALIFORNIA VERY PLEASED SUPPORT
MR APPROVALS FOR CONFIRMATION
AND APPRECIATE ALL THE- HARD
WORK BUT PASSED SEVERAL YEARS-
ESPECIALLY HAVING AN BOARD
HEADING INTO THIS CHALLENGING
TIME. AND FOR MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. OUR FINAL LINING
CUE FROM THE PHONES AS LINE.
TWENTY NINE. TRANSACTION ERIN
RODRIGUEZ UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS CALLING A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THE REQUIREMENT
CONFIRMATION CARE ACT WON'T
EVEN SUCH A STRONG PROPONENT OF
CLEAN DRINKING WATER AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE AND LIKE
WORKING CONTINUE LEADERSHIP
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY MISTER MODERATOR THANK YOU
WILL PROBABLY BE BACK WITH YOU
IN JUST A MOMENT. I HAVEN'T
HEARD FROM WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. I WILL NOW FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION LET ME START IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE WHICH IS
WHERE WE ARE. I SEE NO ONE
APPROACH IN THE DYESS ARE I
WILL TAKE A LOOK INTO ROOM ONE
TWELVE NO ONE IS PRESENT THERE.
SO ALREADY MISTER MODERATOR WE
ARE BACK WITH YOU. TO SEE IF
THERE ARE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU THE STATE
OPPOSITION TO THIS APPOINTMENT
ME PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. ONCE AGAIN
THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
PLEASE. I'M SURE THERE ARE NO
OUTLINED IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MODERATOR- WE WILL TALK WITH
YOU A BIT LATER IN THE HEARING
SO HAVING- GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY
TO HEAR FROM PEOPLE IN SUPPORT
AND IN OPPOSITION I WILL NOW
LOOK TO SENATOR LAYERED WHO
LOOKS TO BE PREPPED AND READY
TO GO TO MAKE A MOTION YES I
WOULD MOVE THE CONFIRMATION OF
WALKING DESK OF ELLIS CHAIR OF
THE WATER. RESOURCES BOARD.
SENATOR THANK YOU ARE MADAM
SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. BROUGH I PROVIDE THEM
WATER HI. I'M LONGER I FEARED
HI THERE I HATE. AYE AYE
CAPTAIN AYE. FIVE FIVE ZERO.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT IS FIVE
TWO ZERO YOUR CONFIRMATION WILL
ROOM MOVE ON TO OUR SENATE
FLOOR CONGRATULATIONS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH TRULY HUMBLED AND
HONORED THANK YOU WELL THANK
YOU WE APPRECIATE SO MUCH YOUR
SERVICE. WITH THAT I KNOW THAT
I SEE ARE APPOINTEES FOR THE
GAMBLING CONTROL COMMISSION-
WAITING WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A
FIVE MINUTE BREAK- SO WE WILL
BE BACK IN FIVE MINUTES AND WE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
ATTENTION AND YOUR PATIENCE
FIVE MINUTES.
THE GAMBLING
CONTROL COMMISSION HOW MUCH I
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE. I DO
KNOW THAT THE FORMER SENATOR
GALGIANI PROBABLY LOVE THAT
WATER DISCUSSION MORE THAN MOST
I SAW HER TAKEN NOTES. BUT I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU ARE WE
ARE FORTUNATE TO HAVE WITH US
TODAY- FOR MEMBERS ONE CHAIR
PAULA LA BRIE I HOPE I GET YOUR
NAME RIGHT ALL RIGHT
CHAIRWOMAN- AND THE FOLLOWING
COMMISSIONERS FORMER SENATOR
KATHLEEN GALGIANI. MISTER ERIC
HEINZ AND MISTER EDWARD HE- OUT
SO I WANT TO WELCOME EVERYONE
AND WHAT WE WILL DO IS. MAKE
INTRODUCTIONS- IN THE ORDER
THAT I JUST STATED BEGINNING
WITH THE CHAIR. HI MISS PAUL
AGREE AND AFTER ALL OF YOU HAVE
GIVEN YOUR INTRODUCTIONS AND
OPENING STATEMENTS. WILL THEN
GO DIRECTLY TO THE COLLEAGUES
FOR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS SO-
THE TOUR WILL BE A FIRST
FOLLOWED BY A FORMER SENATOR
KATHLEEN GALGIANI AND THEN
COMMISSIONER ERIC HEINZ AND
THEN COMMISSIONER EDWARD YEAST
SO. MADAM CHAIRWOMAN IF YOU
WANT TO GO AHEAD AND INTRODUCE
YOURSELF FEEL FREE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK ANYONE
THAT MIGHT BE WITH YOU AND
THEN. YOUR COMMENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MADAM
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- I REALLY APPRECIATE
THIS OPPORTUNITY BEFORE TO BE
BEFORE YOU TODAY AS I SEE- THIS
UP- CONFIRMATION. I THANK THE
GOVERNOR FOR MAKING THAT THIS
QUITE A BIT AND- INTERESTING
MEANS REALLY IMPORTANT ROLE. I
I AM JOINED TODAY BY MY HUSBAND
JIM NICHOLS- HE'S BEEN AN
ABSOLUTE ROCK AND HAS SUPPORTED
ME IN ALL OF MY ENDEAVORS. AS
WELL. THEIR NAMES ARE IDA
DANIEL JOHN PAMPA TRISTIAN
STEVEN. AND THEY HAVE REMAIN
SOME OF MY BEST FRIENDS FROM
CHILDHOOD TO THE STATE AND HAVE
BEEN NOW MY BIGGEST SUPPORTERS
AS WELL. SO I SERVED ON THE
COMMISSION NOW FOR OVER FOUR
YEARS AND DISAPPOINTED AND SAT
IN THE CHAIR POSITION IN
JANUARY. I SAW THE RE
APPOINTMENT BECAUSE I REALLY
ENJOY THE WORK- OF THE
COMMISSION AND I FOUND TO BE A
GOOD FIT. FOR MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES MY ACADEMIC
EXPERIENCES OF MY PROFESSIONAL
EXPERIENCES. I HAVE BEEN
INCREDIBLY SMART AND DEDICATED
STAFF WHO CARE DEEPLY ABOUT THE
MISSION- THE COMMISSION. AND
WORK ON A DAILY BASIS- SO HARD
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
PRESERVING THE INTEGRITY. OF
THE INDUSTRY. AND MY ROLE AS
CHAIR MY GOALS ARE TO CONTINUE
TO ENHANCE EDUCATION TO THE
INDUSTRY AND ITS EMPLOYEES. I'M
REALLY PROUD OF THE WORK THAT
WE'VE DONE IN THE SPACE-
CREATING. TRAINING SESSIONS ON
OUR WEBSITE ARE FOR EMPLOYEES
TO BE ABLE TO. FIND INFORMATION
AND VIEW IT ON YOUTUBE AND IT'S
IN SEVERAL DIFFERENT LANGUAGES-
FLYERS AND PAMPHLETS THAT WE
PUT OUT TO HELP. OUT THE KIDS
ALONG AND I SAY THAT BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE SOME OF THE. APPLICANTS
THAT COME BEFORE US. BARBARA
THAT ARE THE FIRST- WORKING OR-
APPLYING FOR THAT REQUIRES A
LICENSE AND THAT PROCESSES CAN
BE CONFUSING SO WE REALLY WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE.
TRANSPOSING SALAS CLEARLY AS
POSSIBLE I'M FOR THEM SO THEY
CAN GET THROUGH THE APPLICATION
PROCESS- AND MAKE IT EASY FOR
THEM. TODO THAT. SO I WANT TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON EDUCATION
PROJECTS. AND HAVING A GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE BUREAU
AND THE INDUSTRY IS SO
IMPORTANT IN THIS ROLE- WE WANT
TO CONTINUE THE WORK THAT WE'VE
DONE IN THAT SPACE. AND
DEVELOP- STAFF ARE FINISH UP
REGULATIONS THAT STARTED WHEN
I- WHEN WE STARTED WHEN I WAS-
AS SERVICE COMMISSIONER. AND I
JUST LOOK FORWARD TO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPROVAL BOND ON
THE INDUSTRY OVERALL
REGULATIONS- AND PROCESSES AND
PROCEDURES. AND I KNOW THAT MY
JOB WILL BE TO. LISTEN- DESERVE
THEY INTEGRITY IN THE INDUSTRY
RESERVE PUBLIC SAFETY. CONTINUE
WITH THE TRANSPARENCY THAT
WE'VE ESTABLISHED- WORK- FOR
FAIR SOLUTIONS AND- HAVE
EMPATHY AND FOLLOW THE LAW AND
ADVOCATE WHEN CHANGE IS
NECESSARY. AND FINALLY I AM
VERY HAPPY TO HAVE A FULL FIVE
MEMBER COMMISSION. THREE OF
THEM RECENTLY APPOINTED ARE
BEFORE YOU TODAY WE HAVE ONE
OTHER WHO IS NOT YET BEFORE YOU
BUT THEY'RE ALL FAIRLY NEW. AND
SO I WANT TO ASSURE THAT THEY
HAVE ALL THE TOOLS. THAT THEY
NEED- TO. GET GET ON BOARD AND-
ENJOY THE WORK OF THE
COMMISSION AS WELL AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE ALL OF
THE FIVE DISCIPLINES WE HAVE A
MEMBER FROM THE GENERAL PUBLIC
WE HAVE. A FINANCE PERSON WE
HAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT WE HAVE
GOVERNMENT BUSINESS AND LEGAL
AND REGULATORY AND SOMEONE
FROM- PUBLIC AT LARGE. AND I
THINK THAT'S A REALLY-
IMPORTANT- IMPORTANT MAKES AN
ALL WITH ALL THOSE DIFFERENT
DISCIPLINES IT WILL CALL FOR
SOME HELP THE ROBUST. I'M
THINKING AND DISCUSSIONS WERE
ABLE TO DISCUSS THE MATTERS
AND- WE HAVE A REALLY DIVERSE
INDUSTRY AND I THINK THAT THAT
TO HAVING THIS FULL COMMISSION
WILL WILL CERTAINLY- STRENGTH
IN. ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO TO
HELP THE INDUSTRY ALSO AND-
I'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE. CHERBURY
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ODD
KICKING THIS OFF AND GIVEN US A
ACTUALLY A REALLY GOOD
OVERVIEW- OF THE COMMISSION. I
SENATOR FORMER SENATOR K.
KATHLEEN GALGIANI GO FOR GO
AHEAD WELCOME. YOU NEED TO UN
MUTE KATHLEEN. CAN YOU HEAR ME
NOW YES WE CAN THANK YOU MADAM
PRO TEM IT'S WONDERFUL TO SEE
ALL OF YOU TODAY AND I WANT YOU
TO KNOW HOW MUCH I STILL MISS
WORK IN MY FIELD I WANT TO
THANK MY WIFE MERRILL AFTER
KNOCK FOR JOINING ME AND I WANT
TO THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR THIS
APPOINTMENT. I THOUGHT THIS
APPOINTMENT BECAUSE I WANTED TO
BE ABLE TO CONTINUE MY PUBLIC
SERVICE IN AN AREA THAT HAS
LONG BEEN OF INTEREST AND ONE
THAT I HAVE WATCHED EVOLVES
OVER TIME MY INTEREST IN
GAINING STARTED ABOUT TWENTY
YEARS AGO WHEN I WAS FORMER
CHIEF OF STAFF TODAY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BARBARA MATTHEWS. AND I
JOIN TRYING TO TRIP SPONSORED
BY FORMER ASSEMBLY SPEAKER HERB
WESSON VISIT TRIBES THAT WERE
JUST BEGINNINGTO OPERATE
CASINOS AND TEMPORARY
STRUCTURES AND IT WAS
FASCINATING TO HEAR FIRST HAND
HOW TRIBAL LEADERS COLLABORATED
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
EXPAND ROADS PROVIDE FIRE
SERVICE ACCESS WATER AND EXPAND
SERVICES FOR THEIR TRIBAL
MEMBERS. SO I AM VERY GRATEFUL
TO SERVE IN MY NEW CAPACITY
WORKING DIRECTLY WITH THOSE WHO
ARE SEEKING TO WORK WITHIN
CALIFORNIA'S CONTROLLED GAMING
INDUSTRY. I WAS APPOINTED ON
APRIL THIRTIETH OF THIS YEAR SO
I WANT TO THANK OUR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR STACEY WANNA BAXTER
WHO'S BEEN A WEALTH OF
INFORMATION ON BRINGING ME UP
TO SPEED SO THAT I CAN BE
PREPARED FOR MY FIRST MEETINGS.
AND I WANT TO THANK THE SENATE
STAFF SENATE STAFF WHO
PARTICIPATED IN OUR PRELIMINARY
INTERVIEW FOR THEIR THOUGHTFUL
AND TIME RELEVANT QUESTIONS
DURING THE INTERVIEW PROCESS
YOU CHALLENGE ME AND YOU SPREAD
MY THIRST FOR KNOWLEDGE
SPECIFICALLY REGARDING WHAT
HAPPENED DURING CLOTHING AND
WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN OTHER
STATES WITH REGARD TO. A
GAMBLING ESTABLISHMENTS IN
CASINOS WHILE I'M IN A NEW
WORLD TODAY I WILL ALWAYS
APPRECIATE THE CHALLENGING ROLE
THAT US LEGISLATORS HAVE. IN
BALANCING THE NEED I AM VERY
STAKEHOLDER. AND CRAFTING
POLICY TO MEET. THAT FACE THE
END TO. SO IT'S MY GOAL TO EDGE
MY AS MUCH AS I CAN. BECAUSE
SHOULD THE NEED ARISE FOR YOU
TO BE ABLE TO WORK WITH THE
COMMISSION I WOULD HOPE TO HAVE
THAT PRIVILEGE ONCE AGAIN. AND
YOU HAVE MY FULL COMMITMENT
THAT IF CONFIRMED I WILL
CONTINUE TO APPROACH APPROACH
MY WALL AS A COMMISSIONER WITH
THE SAME SET OF VALUES THAT I
APPROACH MY ROLE. AS A
LEGISLATOR AND I WILL ALWAYS
REMEMBER THAT THE LIVELIHOODS
OF OUR APPLICANTS DEPEND ON THE
DECISIONS THAT WE MAKE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SO
MUCH COMMISSIONER HINES WELCOME
DEBTS. HELLO MY NAME IS ERIC
KINDS AND I FIRST OF ALL THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THE OTHER
CENTERS OF THE- COMMITTEE FOR
VERY OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE AT
ADDRESS YOU ALL I AM JOINED
HERE BY MY HUSBAND DAVID SWORE
I WANT TO THANK FOR HIS ONGOING
SUPPORT AND- UNDERSTANDING AND-
THAT MAKES WHAT I DO- POSSIBLE
INTOLERABLE. AND I'M ALSO
JOINED BY A FEW FRIENDS WHO'VE
NEVER PARTICIPATED IN ANYTHING
LIKE THIS ARE REALLY GOVERNMENT
AND I'M HOPING THEY GET SO
EXCITED ABOUT GOVERNMENT THE
BUSINESS OF GOVERNMENT AS I AM.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THINK
CHIRLA BRIE AND- THE
COMMISSION- DAY COMMISSION
STAFF ESPECIALLY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE BAXTER WHO- IN
THEIR ON BOARDING PROCESS AND
THEIR PATIENTS WITH ME AS I TRY
TO NAVIGATE SOME OF. THE STUFF
ON HERE AND IT'S BEEN VERY
EXCITING TO DO THAT AND ALSO
THINK THE OTHER COMMISSIONERS
WHO ARE NEW. MENU ARE NEWER
THAN I AM- BUT BRING A VERY
UNIQUE VOICE AND EXPERIENCE AND
LENDS TO THE TABLE AND I'VE%
ALREADY LEARNED SO MUCH FROM
THEM. I HAD JUST RETIRED- TWO
YEARS AGO FROM TEACHING AND- OF
COURSE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
BUT I WASN'T READY TO YET DO
ALL THE THINGS THAT US RETIREES
ARE SUPPOSED TO STEREO
TYPICALLY DO I DON'T KNOW IF
THEY ARE- YOU KNOW. BASEBALL OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT AND BUT ALSO
AS A AS AN IMMIGRANT AND
NATURALIZED CITIZEN I FELT A
SPECIAL RESPONSIBILITY TO TRY
AND SERVING YOUR BACK AS I
COULD. WHEN THE OPPORTUNITY OF
THE- GAMBLING COMMISSION CAME
UP I FELT IT WAS A GOOD UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY AS A PUBLIC MEMBER-
TO BRING THE PUBLIC'S VOICE TO
THE COMMISSION SOMETIMES A
GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRACY CAN BE
VERY COMPLICATED. AND
INTIMIDATING. AND EXTREMELY.
RESTRAINING AND SO- SOME OF MY
GOALS ARE TO HELP THE- IS ALL
BEEN AND TRANSPARENT AND UNDER.
THAT DOG THAT THOSE ARE THEIR
C. LICENSES OR PERMITS OR
WHATEVER ACTUALLY UNDERSTAND
THE PROCESS THAT WE- CONTINUE
TO EVALUATE THE EDUCATIONAL
PIECE OF THE- THAT THE
COMMISSION IS DOING- WHETHER
IT'S AWARENESS AROUND THE
INDUSTRY ON THE LICENSING
PROCESS. AND THAT WE REMAIN NOT
RESPONSIVE TO OUR CHANGING
ENVIRONMENT WHETHER IT'S
RESPONDING TO- KOVIN OR NEW
CLIMATE CHANGES THAT ARE
HAPPENING TOO MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES WHERE FIRES OR
DROUGHT OR- THINGS LIKE THAT.
AND WHILE WE DO THAT ALSO TO
REMAIN ACTIVELY VIGILANT. THAT
WE DON'T ON INTENTIONALLY SET
UP BARRIERS TO PARTICIPATION
AND ACCESS WHETHER THOSE
BERIA'S OR INSTITUTIONAL RACISM
OR LANGUAGE BARRIERS OR OTHER
THINGS LIKE THAT. ALL AND RULES
PROCESS IS ALSO. AND ACCESSIBLE
AND- THAT THE PARTICIPATION IS
ENCOURAGED AND ACTUALLY
AUTHENTIC AND I WANT TO WILL
MAKE SURE THAT OUR SYSTEM
CONTINUES TO WORK SMOOTHLY
BETTER COMMUNICATION WHETHER
IT'S BETWEEN. AL AGENCIES
WHETHER IT'S BETWEEN THE PUBLIC
AND THE AND THE GOVERNMENT OR
WHETHER IT'S BETWEEN COMPETING
INTERESTS ARE AND CONTINUE TO
BE SMOOTH AND ONGOING AND THAT
WE ARE ABLE TO SEE THROUGH THE
SOMETIMES. THE NOISE AND THE
TRAUMA THAT ACCOMPANIES CHANGE
AND UNDERSTAND WHAT THE REAL
UNDERLYING ISSUES ARE I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO LEARN
AND TO PARTICIPATE AND
CONTRIBUTE TO THE PROCESS AND I
AM. THANKFUL AND HUMBLED TO BE
TO BE HERE TO BE- TO CONTINUE
TO DO THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
COMMISSIONER- TURNING NOW TO
COMMISSIONER YE WELCOME. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME. I
LIKE TO START THIS OPPORTUNITY
BY THANKING SENATE PRO TEM
ACTIONS AND VICE CHAIR BATES
AND DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE. BY
MODERATE IS SCHEDULED TO BE
HERE THIS AFTERNOON.
UNFORTUNATELY MY FAMILY WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO JOIN ME IN
PERSON THEY'RE TRYING TO
GRADUALLY I LIKE THE STORE
THANK THEM ESPECIALLY MY WIFE
OF TWENTY EIGHT YEARS PATRICIA
G. SHE'S BEEN MY ROCK AND
CONFIDENT MY TWO SONS JOHN AND
ALEX. LOVE AND SUPPORT DURING
MY ENTIRE LAW ENFORCEMENT
CAREER AS WELL AS ANYTHING I
DO. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK
MY PARENTS ESPECIALLY MY FATHER
THAT'S NO LONGER WITH US. FOR
THEIR LOVE AND SUPPORT AND FOR-
BASICALLY. EVERYTHING THAT MADE.
COUNTRY ALSO LIKE TO THANK MY
BROTHER MY SISTER HELEN SO AS
MY NIECE CATHERINE CALLAHAN
MCCARTY JOHN TO FOR. A
SUPPORTING VIRTUALLY THERE
PROBABLY ON THE LINE AS WELL- I
LIKE TO START WILL BE STANDING
BY STATE THANK YOU TO GOVERNOR
GAVIN NEWSOM FOR THIS
APPOINTMENT. AS A COMMISSIONER
TO CALIFORNIA GAMBLING CONTROL
COMMISSION. MY NAME IS EDWARD
E. I CAME HERE FROM UNITED I
EMIGRATE TO UNITED STATES AT
THE AGE OF FOUR FROM HONG KONG.
AS I WAS GROWING UP I REALIZED
THAT MY PARENTS HAVE SACRIFICED.
LEAVING THEIR PARENTS FRIENDS
AND OTHER RELATIVES BEHIND SO
THAT MY BROTHER AND SISTER I
CAN COME TO THE UNITED STATES
TO HAVE A BETTER LIFE. BETTER
EDUCATION AND JUST GREAT
OPPORTUNITIES GOING UP HERE. MY
PARENTS ARE TOM ALWAYS THAT
NOTHING WILL BE HANDED TO YOU-
YOU MUST WORK HARD TO ACHIEVE
YOUR GOALS. I THOUGHT I ALSO
TOLD ME THAT HE ALWAYS WANTED
WE ATTEND WEST POINT. WHEN I
REALIZED IT WAS SO HARD TO GET
IN- SO I WANTED. MAKE MY FRIEND
PROUD WENT TO. GET BACK TO THE
SCRIPT. SO I SAW MY SERVICE BY
JOINING THE UNITED STATES
MARINE CORPS RESERVE. AT AGE
SEVENTEEN AND I JANET GOOD
COUNTY SAN DIEGO JUST. ONE WE
GOT TO GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL.
AFTER FILLING MY EIGHT YEAR
CONTRACT I WAS ON THE
DISCHARGED AS A NONTRADITIONAL
ST EIGHTEEN NINETY FIVE. I KNEW
THAT THIS WAS JUST THE
BEGINNING OF MY JOURNEY. MARCH
OF THIS YEAR AND I'M CHARLES A
PEACE OFFICER WITH OVER TWENTY
SEVEN AND A HALF YEARS IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT. MOST OF MY LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAREER HAD BEEN
INVESTIGATIONS. AND I PRETTY
MUCH HAVE INVESTIGATING EVERY
CRIME YOU CAN IMAGINE. IN MY
TENURE AS A CAR. I HAVE ALSO
WORKED UNDERCOVER IMPOSES A
GANGSTER FOR SEVERAL YEARS.
INFILTRATING MANY CRIMINAL
ORGANIZATIONS. START CHOPPING
MY LIFE AND BEING ABLE TO
CONTINUE MY SERVICE ON THIS
COMMISSION. THE STATE IS AN
HONOR AND A PRIVILEGE.
EXPERIENCE AND BACKGROUND I
HAVE ASCERTAINED. FROM THE
MILITARY. AS OFFICER AND BEING
ON MORE MEMBER ON MANY
DIFFERENT LAW ENFORCEMENT
SOLICITATIONS. WILL GIVE ME THE
INSIGHT. AND KNOWLEDGE AND
FORTITUDE. TO ALLOW ME TO ASK
THE RIGHT QUESTIONS. TO MAKE
FAIR AND IMPARTIAL DECISIONS
WHILE SERVING ON THIS
COMMISSION. THE GAMING INDUSTRY
IS SO DIVERSE AND CHANGING ALL
THE TIME. AS A NEW COMMISSIONER
I WILL WORK TO EXPAND MY.
KNOWLEDGE ON THE GAME LOS. I
FORWARD TO LEARNING. AND
WORKING OUR STATE LIKE. I GAME.
MY FELLOW CAN. EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND THE COMMISSION
STAFF. I AM VERY HUMBLED TO BE
HERE TODAY AND I AM A PRODUCT
OF THE AMERICAN DREAM. I WANT
TO CONTINUE TO GIVE BACK AND
SERVE BECAUSE THIS COUNTRY HAS
GIVEN MUCH TO MY FAMILY NINE.
AGAIN I THANK YOU THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE AND YOUR STAFF
FOR YOUR CONTINUE SERVICE. AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE
FOR ME THANK YOU SO MUCH.
COMMISSIONER THANK YOU ARE WITH
THAT I'M GOING TO GO RIGHT TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. AND I
TO THEM I WOULD ASK YOU TO
DIRECT YOUR QUESTION TO A
PARTICULAR COMMISSIONER OR TO
THE CHAIR- SO THAT WE CAN
FACILITATE THIS IN A ORGANIZED
FASHION AND PEOPLE KNOW WHEN TO
SPEAK WENT ON MUTE OR- AND TO
SPEAK. SO SENATOR COME LONGER
IF YOU'RE OKAY I'M SORRY MADE
COUGH I'M GOOD ENOUGH TO- I'M
GOING TO START WITH YOU THIS
TIME AND EQUITY AND FAIRNESS-
AS WE GO AROUND THE ROOM SO GO
AHEAD THANK YOU SO MUCH. SHE
ATE YOU I JUST ACTUALLY DON'T
HAVE THAT MANY QUESTIONS AND I
PROBABLY WILL NOT ASK A
QUESTION OF EVERYONE. HERE
BLESSINGS- BUT I DID HAVE A
QUESTION FOR- SENATOR GALGIANI-
ABOUT- SPORTS BETTING- IT'S A
REAL THING I MEAN WE HAVE CARD
CLUBS WE ALSO HAVE HORSE
TRACKS- WARS RACING TRACKS. AND
CASINOS AND SPORTS BETTING OUR
IS BECOMING A GREATER AND
GREATER ISSUE AS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT REVENUE DIVERSIFICATION-
FOR MANY OF THESE- ARE FOR THIS
INDUSTRY AND JUST WANTED YOUR
THOUGHTS ON HOW THE COMMISSION
SHOULD BE INVOLVED IN THE
SHAPING OF SPORTS BETTING. WELL
AT THIS POINT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS NOT IDENTIFIED ANY TYPE OF
MOBILE FOR THE COMMISSION BUT
IN NOTING THAT AND BE-
CALIFORNIA SPORTS WAGERING
REGULATION AND LAWFUL GAMBLING
ENFORCEMENT ACT HAS QUALIFIED
FOR THE NOVEMBER. TWENTY TWO
TWENTY TWENTY TWO BALLOT- I
READ THROUGH IT AND NOTICED
THAT WHILE THERE'S REFERENCE
TO. THE BUREAU OF GAMBLING
CONTROL AND THEIR WALL THERE IS
NO REFERENCE TO THE COMMISSION.
SO I AM PREPARED TO WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE IF THAT NEED
ARISES AND LOOK LOOK FORWARD TO
THAT OPPORTUNITY I KNOW THAT AS
PART OF REQUIREMENTS FROM
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION AUTHORED
BY A FORMER PRO TEM STEINBERG.
THE LEGISLATURE WILL HOLD A
JOINT PUBLIC HEARINGS ON THE
BALLOT MEASURE AND THERE WILL
BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC
INPUT THERE WILL BE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR QUESTIONS FROM
LEGISLATORS. AND AT THAT POINT
I BELIEVE IT WILL SHED SOME
LIGHT ON- SOME THINGS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MAY NEED TO
CONSIDER AND FOLLOW LEFT
LEGISLATION IF THE BALLOT
MEASURE. DOES INDEED PASS AND
IF THE LEGISLATURE WISHES I
WOULD REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING UNTIL AT PROVIDE
INFORMATION AND ASSIST YOU IN
WHATEVER CAPACITY WHICH. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THAT WAS A SOFT.
I'M SHE IT VERY WELL. YOU'RE
WELCOME- AND THEN MY LAST
QUESTION IS JUST FOR- MISTER
YOU GIVEN THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE- IN YOUR PRIOR LIFE AS A
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER AND
GOING UNDER COVER I'M AND I
THINK DISCUSSIONS THAT- YOU HAD
AROUND- WANTING THE COMMISSION
TO HAVE MORE FLEXIBILITY IN
THEIR DECISION MAKING PROCESS.
JUST WANTED YOUR THOUGHTS ON
WHAT ACTIONS USING THE
COMMISSION CAN TAKE ON ITS OWN
TIME TO GIVE YOURSELF MORE
FLEXIBILITY IN HOW YOU APPROVE
AND DENY- APPLICATIONS AND
POSSIBLY HOW YOU CAN WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE TO MAKE THOSE
CHANGES. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE QUESTION- BASICALLY WHEN I
WAS REFERRING TO DISCRETION HI
SITTING ON THE COMMISSION ALAS.
SB FIVE MONTHS NOW I ATTENDED-
NUMEROUS POTENTIALLY HEARINGS
AS WELL AS COMMISSION MEETINGS
LICENSING AND- A LOT OF- THE
AFRICANS ARE COMING IN- YOU
KNOW THEY ARE AFRAID OF YOU
KNOW. COMING IN AND ASKING
QUESTIONS AND A LOT OF TIMES A
BASICALLY ARE UNTRUTHFUL OR THE
AGES ARE AFRAID TO BASICALLY
TELL US EVERYTHING THAT'S GOING
ON BACKGROUND. WHEN I WAS
REFERRING TO HAVING MORE
DISCRETION I GUESS WHAT I WAS
MEANING WAS THAT- IN THE END- A
LOT OF. BARCLAYS THAT THE STATE.
PUT IN PLACE. MANY YEARS AGO- I
HAVE NO FLEXIBILITY FOR
MANDATORY DISCRETION- I WANTED
TO BASICALLY STATE THAT. IT
WILL BE THAT THE COMMISSION
HAVE MORE DISCRETION TO AN AREA
MANAGER DISCRETION SO WHAT I
WAS TRYING TO SAY IS THAT FOR
EXAMPLE SOMETHING THAT COMES
IN. AND COMMITTED A MARCH FOR
TO WITHIN TEN YEARS- AND DOES
PERSONALIZED AND WITHIN TEN
YEARS BECAUSE HE S. CONVICTION.
NOW IT IS MANDATORY TO NOT- SO
IF WE HAVE A MORE DISCRETION
THAT WAY BECAUSE THAT PERSON IT
IS SOMETHING HE CAN YEARS AGO
TWENTY YEARS AGO. IS A VERY
DIFFERENT PERSON FROM THAT'S
COMING IN NOW. WE WOULD JUST
LIKE A LITTLE BIT MORE
DISCRETION SO THAT BASED ON
WHAT THIS PERSON COMING IN NOW
TELLING US AND HOW THEY ARE
PRODUCTIVE. MARY AND WORKING IN
THE INDUSTRY FOR FIFTEEN TWENTY
YEARS WE JUST WANNA BE ABLE TO.
ATHOLL DISCRETION THAT WE CAN
SIT DOWN THE STATE LEGISLATURES
TO MAKE AMENDMENTS SO THAT WE
JUST HAVE MORE DISCRETION WHEN
IT COMES TO AREA WHERE WE HAVE
TO MAKE MANDATORY DID NOT.
BECAUSE MAKE A MANDATORY DENIAL
OR SOMEBODY CAN AFFECT THEIR
LIVES- PAYER MEDICAL BENEFITS
THERE ARE YOU KNOW MAKING
MORTGAGE PAYMENT HOUSE WE JUST
WON'T BE ABLE TO BE FAIR
TRANSPARENT. SO THAT WE GET%
EVERYBODY EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT SO THAT THEY CAN GET
EITHER. PROVE OR DENY OUR BASED
ON THE CURRENT SITUATION THAT
PERSON NOW. AND THAT'S WHAT I
WAS TRYING TO CONVEY. FOR MORE
DISCRETION IN. GREAT THANK YOU
FOR THE I JUST I WANT TO SAY
THAT I ALL YOU ALL- IMMENSELY
BECAUSE- AND I LOVE THE FACT
THAT THERE ARE A DIVERSE
BACKGROUNDS- AMONGST YOU ALL-
AND LOOK FORWARD TO BEING ABLE
TO CONFIRM YOU. I JUST ALSO
WANT TO ADD THAT- YOU KNOW THE
FIRST IN ARENA SPORTS BOOK
OPENED I THINK IN WASHINGTON DC
IN MAY. AND OTHERS ARE COMING
ONLINE IN OTHER STATES AND JUST
HOPING THAT YOU ALL WILL USE
THIS- THIS BOARD. TO BE
THOUGHTFUL IN HOW TO BE
HELPFUL- AS THIS INDUSTRY
EVOLVES OUT TO KEEP CALIFORNIA
COMPETITIVE- ESPECIALLY AS IT
RELATES TO GAMING- BECAUSE- I
THINK WE DON'T WANT TO BE LEFT
BEHIND IT'S AN INCREDIBLY-
RICH- INDUSTRY WITH A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR REVENUE AND
GROWTH AND WE CERTAINLY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
COMPETITIVE AS A STATE. SO-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS
TO SERVE AND LOOK FORWARD TO IT
CONFIRMING YOU AT THE RIGHT
TIME. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND-
THANK YOU SENATOR COME LONGER
UP MINUTE VICE CHAIR I THINK
I'M GONNA. MIX IT UP A BIT AND-
ASK YOU TO GO NEXT- THANK THANK
YOU. FOR YOUR SERVICE AND
WELCOME ABOARD ALL YOU NEW
MEMBER SAW YOU HAD A FEW MONTHS
TO GET ACCLIMATED. TO YOU WHAT
IS A VERY VERY OFTEN FONG
PRECONCEIVED. OUR
RESPONSIBILITY ALL THAT YOU
HAVE FOR YOU KNOW THE MANY ON
GAMBLING OPERATIONS THAT ARE.
LIKE HEREIN OUR STATE AND
CERTAINLY OUR POTENTIAL OF ONE
BEING ADDED SO I THINK THAT
QUESTION REGARDING ENOUGH PORTS
VETTING. A WITH WITH WITH A
GOOD ANSWER KATHLEEN GOOD.
THANK YOU. MY POWER. I DO IF I
DO. COME ACROSS SOMETHING IN
HER YOU COULD OR WANT TO WEIGH
IN THIS THE TRYING NAY GRAHAM
FROM. OUR CURRENT BALANCE
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
ACCORDING TO THE INFORMATION
THAT I RECEIVED. AND IT STRUCK
ME AS I WAS LOOKING AT THAT
THAT THAT IS THE ACCESS OVER
THE ONE MILLION THAT GOES TO
THE SMALLER OF DAHLE THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY ONE MACHINES OF
THE TRIBES WITH WITH LESS THAN
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY OF.
GAMBLING I GUESS MACHINES ARE
AND WHEN THOSE ARE MADE OUT AND
THEN WHATEVER'S LEFT GOES INTO
THIS TRIBAL NATION GRANTING
GRANT FUNDED I'M- SAYING THIS
TO YOU BUT ALSO REMINDING
MYSELF OF HOW THE UP. WITH THE
WATERFALL IS. BUT WHEN I WAS
LEADER I WAS- HELLO A NUMBER OF
THE- SMALLER I TRIBES VISITED
ME AND SPOKE ABOUT. THE
SITUATIONS THEY WERE FACING
WHERE FATHER EDUCATION IN HIM
THERE TRY ON THEIR- LANDS OF
THE CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS NEEDED
TO ENSURE. THAT THEY HAVE THE
FACILITIES FOR EDUCATION. THE
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS NEEDED TO
PROVIDE HOUSING. BIG ISSUE WAS
HOUSING ON A COUPLE OF THE
NORTHERN TRIBES IF I REMEMBER
CORRECTLY. HE STRUCK ME OF
SOMETHING THAT SHOULDN'T HAVE
BEEN A PROBLEM. AND WITH THIS
KIND OF OUR FINANCIAL RESOURCE
THAT'S AVAILABLE. ARE SHOULD BE
DIRECTED TO. GRANT SPECIFICALLY
FOR THOSE PARTICULAR TRIBES
THAT ARE STILL STRUGGLING AND
ESPECIALLY AFTER THE PANDEMIC
PROBABLY EVEN MORE SO. FELLOW I
JUST LIKE TO KNOW WHEN GRANTS
ARE GIVEN. DO WE A FAST THAT
KIND OF NEED AND DO WE FOLLOW
UP. TO MAKE SURE THAT MONEY
THAT FOR APPROPRIATED. THROUGH
THAT GRANT PROGRAM AND- TO.
THOSE WHO APPLY- IS GOING INTO
THE KIND OF NEEDS THAT HAVE
BEEN EXPRESSED CERTAINLY TO ME
AND I'M SURE THERE ARE. MANY
OTHERS THAT REALLY NEED TO BE
MADE OUT. YEAH IN A SHORTER
TIME FRAME AND IT WOULD APPEAR
THAT THERE MIGHT BE QUITE A BIT
OF MONEY THERE AND THERE COULD
BE PRIVATE- PUBLIC PARTNERSHIPS
AND IN THE SAME SENSE OF. THE
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS SO- I'M
GOING TO ASK ALL OF YOU TO KIND
OF THINK ABOUT THAT AND GIVE ME
YOUR THOUGHTS ON IT BECAUSE IT
WAS REALLY. HEART WRENCHING
WHEN I HEARD ABOUT FROM OF THE
SITUATIONS THAT WERE. MANY
FAMILIES LIVING ON AND NO ONE
SPECIFIC BUT. FAMILY BOTH HOME
AROUND UNTIL THAT KIND OF COMES.
WITH WILL OF WATER. WILL ENERGY-
AIR CONDITIONING WHAT ALL THE
THAT WE ENJOY AND CERTAINLY A
LOT MORE ON AFFLUENT. TRIBAL
NATIONS OR TRIBES PROBABLY ARE
ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE FOR THEIR
PEOPLE HAVING VISITED A NUMBER
OF BILLS. OVER THE COURSE OF MY
SERVICE HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE
SO HAVE AT IT NICE AND TELL ME
WHAT WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT IT.
AND HOW WE MIGHT ENSURE. THAT
THOSE NEEDS ARE MET THROUGH
THIS GRANT PROGRAM. LET ME ASK
OUR CHAIR OF THE BRIEF YOU
WANNA KICK US OFF ON THAT ONE.
OKAY I'LL DO THAT THANK YOU-
YES IT'S UNFORTUNATE- WHAT
YOU'RE WHAT YOU'RE SAYING. THE
GALLAGHER TRUMP MISSION DOESN'T
HAVE- A SAY SO IN HOW THAT
MONEY IS DISTRIBUTED. ALSO WE
DON'T HAVE A RULE THEY ARE WE
ARE WE JUST WEIRD AND MINISTRY-
THE FUNDS THAT COME THROUGH
THAT- BUT WE DON'T GET TO
DECIDE WHAT THEY'RE SPENT ON.
SO THAT SAID THERE ARE OTHER
FUNDS THAT TIME THERE'S SPECIAL
DISTRIBUTION FUND- IS A PIECE
OF IT AND THAT COMES FROM. I
SHOULD MENTION THE TRIBES AND
THEY TALK ABOUT OTHER CRIMES
BETTER ON CAN'T HAVE CASINOS OR
HAVE ISSUES WITH- FEWER THAN I
THINK MAYBE ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
THREE FIFTY- SLOTS- THERE IS
THE ONLY CONTROL FIND- AND THE
REVENUE SHARING TRUST FUND- SO
WE- BASICALLY. WE'RE FUNDED
THROUGH THE GALA CONTROL FUN
AND THAT'S TO THE OF FEES
ANNUAL FEES THAT ARE PAID OUT-
AND THEN WE ALSO DRAW FROM THE
SPECIAL DISTRIBUTION FUND. FOR
THE TASK THAT WE DID FOR THE
TRIBES UNDER THE COMPACTS WE
ARE DESIGNATED TO DO CERTAIN
THINGS UP FOR THEM BUT THAT'S
SORT OF THE EXTENT OF OUR-
INVOLVEMENT WITH RESPECT TO- TO
IT PLEASE WE DON'T HAVE. A SAY
SO ON HOW THE MONEY GOES SO
THAT IS A SPECIAL DISTRIBUTION
FUND IS SET OUT BY THE CONTACTS
AND ALL THAT SUPPOSED TO GO AND
THEN. WITH THE BRITISH SHARING
TRUST FUND WE DON'T HAVE A
HOME. YEAH BUT WE DON'T HAVE A
ROLE THERE. WELL I KNOW. HOW TO
DISTRIBUTE IT YEAH.ALL IT CAN
ACT. YES GO AHEAD OUR
COMMISSIONER. THANK YOU- I READ
THAT IN ABOUT TWO THOUSAND SO
OR EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADAM
GRAY LEGISLATION THAT SIGNED
INTO LAW THAT PRESCRIBES WHAT
THE COMMISSION'S WALL WOULD BE
IN ADMINISTERING THE FARM AND
LAID OUT HOW THE MONEY WAS TO
BE DISTRIBUTED I DON'T RECALL
ALL OF THE DETAILS OF THAT- BUT
YOU'VE PIQUED MY INTEREST
SENATOR BATES AND I WILL BE
LOOKING BACK AT THAT
LEGISLATION AND ALSO ENQUIRING
ABOUT WHETHER THERE HAVE BEEN.
ANY KIND OF REPORTS THAT- SINCE
THE LEGISLATION WAS PASSED BY
THE LEGISLATURE I WOULD THINK
ALSO THAT IF THERE IS A NEED
TO. MAKE SOME CHANGES TO THAT
THAT THAT SOMETHING THAT COULD
BE DONE AT A FUTURE TIME. IT
WOULD THAT WAS GONNA BE MY
FOLLOW UP QUESTION IS THERE
LEGISLATION. THAT WOULD BE
NEEDED TO ASSIST YOU ALL AND
PERHAPS HAVING A LITTLE MORE
OVERSIGHT THERE I UNDERSTAND A
PANEL DECIDES AND I'M SURE THAT
THAT FOR POINTED BY. ALL THE
TRIBES SITE- TOGETHER ON-
REVIEWING THOSE REQUEST FOR
THOSE APPLICATIONS FOR GRANTS
BUT I THINK IT'S REALLY AN
IMPORTANT THING TO TAKE A LOOK
AT- AT THIS POINT IN. THAT ARE
YOU KNOW LAST TWO YEARS THE
CHALLENGING- TIME THAT WE'VE
BEEN AND BECAUSE OF THE FACT
THAT OFF BUT I'M SURE. OF WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT LOW INCOME AND
YOU KNOW AND- ALL THE THINGS
THAT. OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE
FACED DIFFICULT PARTICULARLY
SIGNIFICANT ONE THAT WITH A
PROBLEM BEFORE. WE GOT INTO THE
PHIRI OF REDUCTION AND NOW
FINANCIAL RESOURCES TO MEET
THESE KINDS OF NEEDS SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT. I AND- I GUESS
THE LAST QUESTION AND MAYBE.
I'LL DROPPING OUT TO. FIFTH
MISTER. FINE HOW THAT HAD A
QUESTION. WE DON'T WANT TO YOU
OUT SO OFTEN. WE SEE MAY PEOPLE
RETURNING TO ALL OF THESE FUN
ACTIVITIES OUT THOROUGHLY
GAMBLING BEING- IMPORTANT WHEN
I TELL YOU THAT WAS- THAT CAN'T
MY MOM GOING FOR THE LAST I
THINK FIVE OR SIX YEARS OF HER
LIFE. EVEN THOUGH SHE SUFFERED
LINE OF THOUGHT THE TIME SHE
COULD STILL TELL WHEN SHE HEARD
A SLOT MACHINE WHAT THE WEATHER
BY YOU KNOW WINNING OR LOSING.
THAT- WE HAVE THE DELTA VARIANT
BACKING BACK AN ARMY AND STAND
UP. HOW ARE WE ARE YOU KNOW
OVERSEEING WHAT MIGHT BE GOING
ON ON ON THE FRENCH WITH- THE
PROTOCOLS THAT ARE IMPORTANT.
TO ENSURE THAT CHILD ABUSE
ESTABLISHMENTS CAN CONTINUE TO
OPERATE AND CERTAINLY DO IT
WITH THE LEAST. RESTART THREAT
TO THE SPREAD OF SPREADER SEND
HIM THE- THING IS THAT I'M NOT
SURE YOU HAVE ANY ROLL OVER
THAT BUT CERTAINLY YOU HAVE.
FIRM KNOWLEDGE AND PERHAPS
SHOULD HAVE OVERSIGHT. IN TERMS
OF THE ENSURING THAT BOTH
PROTOCOLS WHICH ARE. ARE
CERTAINLY NATIONAL UNIVERSALIST
POINT TIME- THAT THEY WERE
BEING EMPLOYED AND YOU KNOW OUR-
YEAH. OF STEP. BEING NOTES ON
TRIBAL LANDS OR OTHERWISE. SURE
AND I WOULD BENEFICIAL THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION- I THINK
THAT- YOU KNOW IT'S CERTAINLY-
I MEAN YOU SERVE ON THE
COMMISSION WHILE INSIDE I MEAN
DURING COLD TIME AND SO MOST OF
THE DAY THE- YOUR NATION SOME
PROCEDURES THAT WERE PUT IN
PLACE- WE'RE DONE BEFORE MY
TIME AND I HAVE TO SAY THAT-
THE COMMISSION. AND THE
COMMISSION STAFF HAS DONE A
REALLY. GOOD JOB OF TRYING TO
ENSURE THAT. ALL THE WORKERS
AND THE PARTICIPANTS IN THAT
THE ESTABLISHMENTS ARE SAFE AND
HEALTHY OF COURSE- THIS IS VERY
MUCH AN UNPRECEDENTED-
TERRITORY I THINK OR AND- AND
OPEN. AND I THINK BOTH THE
INDUSTRY AND PARTICIPANTS AND
EMPLOYEES ARE- YOU KNOW JUST
RECOVERING FROM THE DRIVE FROM
THE TRAUMA OF THE SHUTDOWNS AND
PEOPLE LOSING THEIR JOBS AND-
AND- ALL OF AND THAT'S
PARTICIPATING. UNIT THAT COMES
AS PART OF THAT- I THINK AS WE
RE OPEN AND NOW WE HAVE THE NEW
DELTA VERY COMING UP. AND WE
DON'T REALLY KNOW YET HOW
THAT'S GOING TO- AFFECT
BUSINESSES AND AN EFFECT
BECAUSE FRESH BECAUSE THE-
REALLY DEPENDS A LOT ON
VACCINATION RATES. AND HOW THAT
AFFECTS AND AS WE CONTINUE TO
LEARN AND SCIENCE CONTINUES
TWELVE ALL. AROUND- ACTIONS AND
I THINK THAT WILL NEED TO RE
REACHED AND CAN. TO TALK ABOUT
THAT- ALL THE PROCEDURES ARE
STILL IN PLACE. AS FAR AS I
KNOW AROUND AROUND COVE IN- THE
ENFORCEMENT IS NOT. OF THOSE
ARTICLES ARE REALLY THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE BUREAU
AND I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE CONTINUE TO COMMUNICATE
BETWEEN THE BUREAU AND THE
LICENSING SIDE- TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE THAT THE PROCEDURES
AND PROTOCOLS ARE IN PLACE. AND
THEY CONTINUE TO- NUMBER ONE OF
COURSE KEEP EVERYBODY SAFE AND
HEALTHY AND I THINK THAT SHOULD
BE THE NUMBER ONE. PRIORITY BUT
ALSO THAT THEY CONTINUE TO MEET
THE NEEDS THAT WE NEED THEM TO
DO AND THAT THAT AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE THAT THE THAT THESE-
CAN CONTINUE WHEN PEOPLE CAN GO
BACK TO WORK AND- AND GET THEIR
LIVES BACK IN ORDER AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR ANSWERS ALL OF YOU AND
YOU ALL SEEM VERY. QUALIFIED
FILL UP THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE FANNED OUT. HAVE A GOOD
TIME YOU'VE GOT TO BE A GOOD
TIME YOU GUYS WHO ARE LOOKING
FOR THAT SO. HOPEFULLY WITH
THIS YEAR. THANKS THANK YOU
MADAM VICE CHAIR- SENATOR
GROWTH. IN DEMAND FOR TEN AND-
THE COMMISSIONER HE I HAVE TO
TELL YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE AND THE FIRST FEMALE
VETERAN IT'S EVER SERVED IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE
AND NOW WE SHARE THE SAME RANK
DIFFERENCE- DIFFERENT AT. I
CERTAINLY I SEATS ARMY
RENDERING CARPET SAME RANK
SPECIALTY FOR SO. AND THANK YOU
SIR FOR YOUR SERVICE TO OUR
COUNTRY. THANK YOU. M. GALA G.
GOOD TO SEE YOU. YES SENATOR
THANK YOU I'M EXCITED ABOUT AND
THE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS TO
THIS COMMISSION BECAUSE I
BELIEVE EVERYBODY IS WELL
ROUNDED GIVE IT A BRILLIANT
ATTORNEY OBVIOUSLY BASED ON THE
BACKGROUND THAT I READ- YOU
KNOW YOU HAVELAW ENFORCEMENT
AND SOMEBODY'S DONE
INVESTIGATION WORK AND- OF
COURSE GALGIANI CERTAIN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE
AND- WE KNOW THAT SHE'S ALWAYS
GOING TO BE WILLING TO WORK
WITH BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE TO
MAKE SURE THAT. I'M GOOD POLICY
AND STAMPEDERS TO ADMINISTER- I
DON'T KNOW VERY MUCH ABOUT YOU-
MISTER HINES SORRY. AND BASED
ON WHAT I READ ON YOUR
BACKGROUND. AS SO. BEING A NEW
MEMBER I KNOW THAT YOU'VE BEEN
SERVING FOR US SINCE JANUARY
BELIEVE THAT. WHEN THE
SITUATION RIGHT YES. SINCE THE
END OF JANUARY WHAT ARE YOU
DOING. YOU KNOW I KNOW THE
GAMING INDUSTRY'S IN CAT AND
INCREDIBLY NUANCED- LOTS OF
DIFFERENT REGULATORY ASPECTS-
AND OTHER THINGS THAT HAVE TO
MOVE FORWARD WHAT ARE YOU DOING
TO LEARN ABOUT THE VARIOUS
ASPECTS OF THE INDUSTRY TO HELP
YOU. ON IT INFORM YOUR DECISION
MAKING IN THE PROCESS. SURE
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
SENATOR- I THINK FIRST OF ALL
IT'S- LEARNING ABOUT THE
INDUSTRY ITSELF AND AS YOU SAID
IS VERY NUANCED AND OUR WATER
VERY. COMPETING INTERESTS AS
WELL AS AS NEW ONES INTERESTS
ARE- I DID AND I AND I WENT
VERY STEEP LEARNING CURVE.
ABOUT HOW IT ALL WORKS. AND HE
SAID I THINK THERE ARE SOME
UNIVERSAL ASPECTS ACT THAT JUST
THE FACT. THAT EVERYONE IN
THERE WHEN ONE OF COURSE IS THE
IS KEEPING MY AGE ONLY
EDUCATION UP THERE ARE A LOT OF
ORIOLES ON THE- COMMISSION
WEBSITE THAT ARE NEW- EITHER ON
THE INDUSTRY WORK ARE TARGETED
AT LICENSEES STATE. AS THEY
ENTER THE PROCESS OR JUST BY
AND WATCHING ALL OF THOSE ARE
CONTINUING TO. SPEAK WITH THE-
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ON A
BAXTER AND- THE LEAD ATTORNEYS
AND- THE STAFF AT THE
COMMISSION OFFICE AT LEAST AS
MUCH AS I CAN SINCE WERE WERE
ALL DOING IT ALL VIRTUALLY. AND
EVEN OF INCREDIBLE HELP. TO
BRING ME UP TO SPEED AND HOW
THE INTERESTED INDUSTRY WORKS
BUT AS IMPORTANTLY THE HISTORY
OF HOW OLD THE GIRL UP AND COME
TO THIS POINT- SO IT'S JUST
IT'S JUST AN ONGOING PROCESS
IT'LL BE AWHILE. I THINK WHILE-
TO REALLY FEEL COMFORTABLE AND
KIND OF HIT HIT THAT STRIDE I
TEND TO LOOK AT THINGS LIKE
AGAIN ACCESS A SENSIBILITY
FAIRNESS. I MEAN I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE PROCESS IS GOING
ON THEN OUR CHANCES ARE A LOT
OF PEOPLE JUST ENTERING INTO
THE INDUSTRY ARE LOOKING FOR A
LICENSE FOR TRYING TO GET A
JOB- MIGHT NOT UNDERSTAND IT AS
WELL. AND AS A FRIEND ASKED ME
THE OTHER DAY WHEN I WAS
TALKING ABOUT THIS WITH THEM-
THEY SAID EXPLAINED IT TO ME
LIKE A LIKE I'M A KINDERGARTEN.
AND I FORTUNATELY HAVING TAUGHT
KINDERGARTEN THAT WAS A LITTLE
BIT EASIER FOR ME TO DO TO KIND
OF BREAK IT DOWN- BUT I'M I'M
STILL LEARNING AND I DON'T EVEN
PRETEND TO. KNOW EVERYTHING
YET- BE THE EXPERT THAT I AT
LEAST I HOPE TO BE COMING OUT
SOON AND WITH THE SUPPORT OF
OUR OF OUR OWN CHAIR. AND- AND
STAFFS. THANK YOU. A MAN SURE
JUST HAVE QUESTION FOR YOU IF
THAT'S A- YEAH. YOU KNOW WHAT
THREE. TO THE REYES. THAT WERE
PUT IN PLACE BY THE COMMISSION-
CAN YOU TELL US A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT HOW IT'S AFFECTED THE
INDUSTRY. I'M TALKING ABOUT
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS WITH
KOBE. AND THEN- AT HOW IT'S
AFFECTED THE INDUSTRY AND
SHOULD ANY EMERGENCY RECKITT
REGULATIONS BE CONTINUED OR
SHOULD WE ADOPT NEW
REGULATIONS- FROM WHAT WAS
ADOPTED PREVIOUSLY. OKAY THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION YES SO
THE COMMISSION- IN ADDITION TO
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THE-
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH. AND
OSHA- WAS VERY INSTRUMENTAL IN.
HELPING TO- CROSSING GUIDELINES
FOR THE INDUSTRY- OF COURSE
THEY HAVE THE HARDSHIP LIKE
MANY OF THE BUSINESSES WHEN
THEY HAD TO CLOSE- AND WHEN I
GOT TIME TO RE OPEN. HOW DO
LEVY OPEN SAFELY. SO WORKING
CLOSELY GUIDELINES FOR THEM- TO
SAFELY REOPEN IT ONE OF THOSE
INCLUDED OUTDOOR OPERATIONS
THAN THAT CAME A LITTLE BIT
LATER ON. BUT THE EMERGENCY
BRAKES PACKAGE THEN CONSISTED
OF LET ME LET ME BACK UP JUST
ONE MORE MINUTE IN TERMS OF
THINGS THAT WERE OUTSIDE OF THE
REGULATIONS. SO WE DID- WORK
TO- EXECUTIVE ORDERS IN PLACE
THAT WOULD GIVE THEM SOME
RELIEF BY PUSHING BACK THE
DATE. WHEN FOR EXAMPLE THEIR
FINANCIAL STATEMENTS WERE DUE
WITCHING BACKDATES WHEN THEIR
TABLE FEES WOULD BE DO SO WE
DIDN'T DO THAT A COUPLE OF
TIMES TO GIVE THEM SOME RELIEF.
WHEN THEY HAD TO HAVE THE DOORS
CLOSE FULLY EMERGENCY RENTALS
TO HELP THEM- SAFELY RE OPENED-
THEIR DOORS FOR BUSINESS. AND
AROUND THAT CAME ONE WAS- TO
ALLOW THE COLOR OF MY ACCOUNT.
SOME OF THESE CARTOONS ARE VERY
SMALL AND SO THE- NORMALLY YOU
HAVE TO HAVE SO MANY PEOPLE IN
THE COUNT ROOM BECAUSE YOU NEED
TO HAVE THE WITNESSES AND WE
HAVE TO. THE CHECKS AND
BALANCES SOME OF THEM WERE- ARE
VERY SMALL AND THEIR PROBLEMS
IS VERY SMALL SO THEY CAN
ACCOMMODATE BECAUSE OF SOCIAL
DISTANCING RULES THAT COULD
ACCOMMODATE HAVING THAT NUMBER
OF PEOPLE SET INTO THE ROAD. SO
WE WILL WE ALLOW THEM THE
REGULATION WOULD ALLOW THEM TO
HAVE REMOTE- HAVE SOMEONE
LOOKING REMOTELY TO DO THE
CHECKS AND BALANCES. SO THAT
WAS ONE OF THEM- THE OTHER. WAS
WITH. RESPECT TO- THERE ARE
THERE ARE TALK ABOUT THE FEES
BUT WE RESPECT TO- IF YOU JUST
ALLOW ME ONE SECOND I KIND OF
ABSOLUTELY. ELSEWHERE. SO WE
ARE EVENTUALLY I HAD TO
LEGISLATION BOOK WORK WITH
WHICH IS AB ONE THIRTY SEVEN
AND THAT GAVE THEM RELEASED
FROM- FROM FEES FOR TWO YEAR
PERIOD OF TIME SO WE'RE HAPPY
THAT THAT IS GOING TO AFFECT
INTO LAW AND THAT WOULD GIVE
THEM SOME SOME RELIEF AS WELL.
SO I THINK THAT WHAT WE DID-
ALLOW THEM TO OPEN SAFELY- OPEN
THE DOORS BACK FROM BUSINESS TO
AND- A LOT OF THE PUBLIC BACK
IN I WOULD REQUIRE THEM TO DO
SANITATION PLAN HAVE THAT
SANITATION PLAN- HANDED IN TO
THE TO THE BUREAU INTO THE
COMMISSION SO THAT THEY CAN BE
CHECKED- AND- THAT WOULD ALLOW
THEM TO SAFELY OPEN SO I THINK
IT WAS I THINK WHAT WE DID WAS
VERY HELPFUL FOR THEM AND GOING
FORWARD WE'RE JUST GONNA HAVE
TO SEE- WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO SAY
BECAUSE- AS ERIC MENTIONED WITH
THIS DELTA VARIANT. I DON'T
KNOW THAT SOME F THESE
REGULATIONS. WOULD NEED TO BE
LOOKED AT. WHAT ARE THE THINGS
WE DID TO IS. WHEN WAS GOING TO
BE TIME TO RE. THIS THE JUNE
FIFTY THEY WE WENT BACK WE- THE
RIGHT. AND THE ARE. ADJUSTED SO
THAT. SOME OF THE IT ESPECIALLY
SENATE PLANTS SO THAT THEY
COULD LOOK TO THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS MAKE IT LOOK TO
THE- CDC AND OSHA GUIDELINES IN
ORDER TO COME UP WITH THE PLANS
THAT THEY NEED TO HAVE IN ORDER.
TO DO THE SANITATION SO. SOME
OF THESE CONTINUE. CURRENTLY
THE WAY IT IS THEY BY OPERATION
OF LAW THEY'RE GOING TO EXPIRE.
BUT WE VISIT AND SEE IF THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT MAKES SENSE TO
CONTINUE ON IN THE FUTURE- BY
WAY OF ANOTHER REGULATION. ALSO
WE'RE UNDER- CONSTANTLY
EVALUATING- WHAT THE WHAT. DO I
DO BUT IT IS GOING TO DEPEND A
LOT ON WHAT HAPPENS JUST THIS.
THIS AREA THAT WE CAN'T CONTROL
IT THAT'S WE'RE ALL STRUGGLING
WITH AND- I'M TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO. KEEP THINGS I'M
GOING. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR VERY MUCH AND- I
DON'T HAVE QUESTIONS AGAIN LIKE
MY COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY
AND I HAVE QUESTIONS FOR
EVERYONE. BUT I THINK YOU ALL
FOR BEING A AND GALGIANI IS
REALLY REALLY GOOD TO SEE YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR YOU TO.
SENATOR LAYERED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF IT AS USUALLY THE PRO
TEM SAYS IT IS AN ADVANTAGE TO
GO NEAR THE END. SO I THINK
ALMOST EVERYTHING HAS BEEN
MASSED BAND THAT I WOULD HAVE
VAST AND I ENJOYED THE MEETING
AND- WITH ALL OF YOU IN
DIFFERENT MEETINGS YESTERDAY
AND IT WAS IMPRESSIVE I LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING YOU AND I
DON'T WANT TO BE THE ONLY
PERSON. TO NOT SAY SENATOR
GALGIANI ANSWERED THE QUESTION
WHILE SO. I WILL MAKE THAT
UNANIMOUS DID SERVE WITH HER IN
THE ASSEMBLY SO I HAVE
EXPERIENCE OF THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING THE NOMINEES THANK
YOU- IT THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED AND- YOU KNOW MAYBE A
LITTLE BIT OF FUN AT- SENATOR
GALGIANI SIXPENCE BUT I KNOW
HER TO BE SOMEONE WHO IS ALWAYS
PREPARED. AND IT DID NOT
SURPRISE ME THAT SHE COULD
POINT TO A PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT THAT NONE OF US REMEMBER
BUT- HI I NEED THAT WITH
SINCERITY WARMTH AND- ACTUALLY
RESPECT FOR THE WORK THAT- THAT
SHE DOES I ACTUALLY DO HAVE A
QUICK QUESTION AND MAYBE MADAM
CHAIR I'M HAPPY TO HEAR FROM
ANYONE BUT- FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE GIVEN THAT YOU HAVE
SERVED AWHILE- THE ISSUE OF
CYBER SECURITY ISSUES AND
GAMBLING. JUST GENERALLY
SPEAKING I'M AWARE- THAT
THERE'VE BEEN A COUPLE OF- OUT
REPORTED YBERATTACKS AND THIS
IS AN ISSUE THAT WE ARE C. AND
MORE AND MORE IN ALMOST MANY OF
THE AREAS THAT THIS- COMMITTEE
WHERE WE MAKE CONFIRMATION
APPOINTMENTS. WATER ENERGY-
ANYTHING YOU WANT TO SHARE WITH
US FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE- THAT
THE COMMISSION MAY BE LOOKING
AT I KNOW THIS IMPACTS THE
INDIVIDUAL- ENTITIES BUT-
ANYTHING YOU'VE HAD AN UPDATE
ON THAT YOU WOULD SHARE WITH US
ON CYBER SECURITY. AND CYBER
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION SO
IN CYBER SECURITY IN GENERAL
YEAH SO EACH OF THE- CARD ROOMS
WOULD- HAVE TO HAVE HEIR OWN
PLANS WE DON'T HAVE- BUT AT
LEAST ON THE STATE LEVEL WE
HAVEN'T IMPLEMENTED ANYTHING
FIVE THAT WOULD TO- GIVE THEM
DIRECTION ARE AND- THAT'S
ACTUALLY A VERY VERY
INTERESTING QUITE- AND IS TO MY
KNOWLEDGE WE HAVEN'T BEEN ASKED
BY ANYONE- WITH THAT BUT I WILL
SAY THAT WE DO HAVE A VERY
VERY. STRONG. I. T. TEAM
THEY'RE VERY SMALL BUT THERE
MIGHT BE. AND- GIVE THE AMOUNT
OF THAT WE TO HAND THE MIND
BONTA I. T. NEXT TO DO THE I'M
SURE IN ANY GIVEN TIME. IT IS-
OUR EXPERTISE IF SOMEONE WANTS
TO DROP HONORED EXPERTISE AND
GIVE US- AND- WE WOULD BE HAPPY
TO DO THAT. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT WE ARE BRINGING
THAT UP WITH US. THE
ADMINISTRATION IN TERMS OF I.
T. IN A NUMBER OF WAY SO I
APPRECIATE THAT. I DON'T HAVE
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS FOR
COMMISSIONERS HINES OR EASY BUT
TO EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION
ALSO- TO YOU FOR YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO STEP UP AND DO
THIS WORK- WITH THAT- I'M GOING
TO GO TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
AND AS ALWAYS WE'RE GOING TO GO
FIRST TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO WANT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT- I
DO ACTUALLY SEE SOMEONE IN THE
ROOM STANDING UP APPROACH IN
THE DYESS SO. LET ME WELCOME
YOU REMIND YOU OF DISTANCE AND
ALL OF THAT AND SAY WELCOME TO
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION OF ANY
AND YOUR POSITION AND OBVIOUSLY
WE'VE GOT. A CHAIR AND A THREE
MEMBER SO PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK
YOU MANAGER MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
MIKE AND IT'S AND I'M HERE IN
MY INDIVIDUAL CAPACITY AS A
MEMBER THE CATHOLIC COMMUNITY.
IN SUPPORT OF MISS LIBERTY WHO
IS A LONGTIME FRIEND AND
COLLEAGUE OF MINE. A TRULY A
REMARKABLE PERSON I SPENT A
GOOD PART OF MY CAREER TRYING
TO KEEP UP WITH HER. VERY
DIFFICULT TO DO I HAVE WORKED
WITH A NUMBER OF CHALLENGING
ISSUES IN A SENIOR PERFORMED.
WITH COMPOSURE AND CLASS UNDER
PRESSURE AND ADVERSE
CIRCUMSTANCES. I'VE ALSO SEEN
OUR MAKE PERSONAL SACRIFICES TO
HELP AND BENEFIT OTHERS WHICH
IS SOMETHING I DEEPLY RESPECT.
WHEN SHE HAS ALWAYS
DEMONSTRATED THE HIGHEST LEVELS
OF INTEGRITY. DEDICATION AND
CREATIVITY TO HER WORK IN OUR
PERSONAL LIVES. SHE IS AN
EXCELLENT CHOICE AND
COMPETITION WILL DO AN
EXEMPLARY JOB FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA- AND IF YOU HAD
LISTENED WITH WHAT SHE SAID
REALLY STRUCK ME SHE SAID ONE
OF HER PLANS WAS TO LISTEN WITH
EMPATHY WHICH- PERSONALLY I
THINK SHOULD BE. A REQUIREMENT
FOR ANYONE WHO'S GOING TO MAKE
DECISIONS. ABOUT PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA AND SO I'M I'M I
APPLAUD THE NON. AND VERY
PLEASED TO SUPPORT HER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND ALTHOUGH I'VE
NEVER CALLED HER GALA G. IF-
GALGIANI SOMEONE TO VOUCH FOR
I'M HAPPY TO DO THAT TO. THANK
YOU SO MUCH- I SEE NO ONE ELSE
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
I'M JUST GONNA TAKE A QUICK
LOOK AT ROOM ONE TWELVE- WE
HAVE NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THERE SO I'M GOING TO WELCOME
BACK OUR MODERATOR- TO PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. AND MISTER MODERATOR
WELCOME BACK. THANK YOU. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE NOMINEES ARE APPOINTEES
I APOLOGIZE FOR HUMANE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. BUT AGAIN THAT'S ONE
AND THEN ZERO. WE DO HAVE AFEW
LINES IN Q. LOCAL FIRST ONLINE.
THIRTY TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM APPROACH AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS JASON
BRANCH ON BEHALF OF PLAYER AND
SERVICES. THE CALIFORNIA BASED
COMPANY THAT SPECIALIZES IN
THIRD PARTY PROVIDER PLAYER
SERVICES. WORKING WITH A NUMBER
OF LICENSE CARD ROOMS IN CASINO
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THAT
WHEREIN SERVICES THREE SHE'S
THE QUALIFICATIONS AND
PERSPECTIVES OF EACH OF THESE
APPOINTEES. AND WHAT THEY BRING
TO THEIR JOB AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMISSION STARTING TRUMP
POLICY ADMINISTRATION. ONE THAT
GAMBLING CONTROL ACT. A DOG
PERSON NAY POINT NO THE PORK
BEING. FOR CONFIRMATION THE
COMMITTEE TODAY. J. U. S. OPEN
THIS UP FOR THE PUBLIC IN
ALLOWING US TO. INDICATE OUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. BELYING. NINETEEN BUT
AFTERNOON MADAM KO TAMA AND
MEMBERS TALENT KIDS
REPRESENTING MYSELF TODAY AND
HONORED TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT
FOR APOLLO AGREE TO THE CHAIR
OF THE CALIFORNIA GAMBLING
CONTROL COMMISSION. I HAVE
KNOWN MR THREE PERSONALLY AND
PROFESSIONALLY FOR MORE THAN
TWO DECADES HAVING WORKED IN
AND AROUND THE CAPITOL BUILDING
DURING THIS PERIOD OF TIME. I
HAVE KNOWN HER TO BE A CHAMPION
FOR GOOD GOVERNMENT AND
ATTENTIVE TO CONSTITUENT NEEDS.
THERE'S BEEN TIMES WHERE WE'VE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
CLOSELY TOGETHERON PARTICULAR
PROJECTS AND FOR THAT I'M
GRATEFUL AND HONORED TO BE HERE
TODAY TO REPRESENT TO HAVE.
THAT HURTS MY SUPPORT FOR HER.
FOR THESE REASONS AND THE
REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED BY
OTHERS- I URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
HER APPOINTMENT AS CHAIR TO THE
CALIFORNIA GAMBLING COMMISSION.
I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO GET MIND
ME TO SUPPORT PRIMARY SENATOR
GALGIANI- WHO'S ALSO-
NOMINATION MY FORMER COWORKER
AND REPRESENTATIVES OF MY
HOMETOWN AND I ALSO LIKE TO
URGE SUPPORT AS WELL THANK YOU
MEMBERS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. LINE.
THIRTY ONE. THIRTY NINE THIRTY
ONE YOUR PHONE MAY BE I MEAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM PRO CHAIR
AND- OKAY I'M AND VICE CHAIR
BATES MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MICHAEL GETTING HERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION BUT REPRESENTING-
MYSELF AND THE CAPITAL AS A
MEMBER OF THE CAPITAL COMMUNITY
I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE CONFIRMATION OF CHAIR
PAULA LIBRARY. I'VE KNOWN AND
WORKED WITH ALL OF FOR THE PAST
TWENTY YEARS AND I THINK HER
EXPERIENCE WITH THE LOTTERY
COMMISSION OF COURSE NOW WITH
THE GAMBLING COMMISSION
DEMONSTRATED HER CAPABILITIES
YOU CARD FROM MY OTHER
COLLEAGUES ABOUT HER OTHER
EXPERIENCES I AGREE WITH THOSE.
I'D BE MAD AT MYSELF IF I
DIDN'T ALSO OFFER SUPPORT FOR
MY GOOD FRIEND SENATOR GALGIANI
OR COMMISSIONER GALGIANI SO
WITH THAT IRISH CONFIRMATION OF
ALL THE CANDIDATES AND THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NINE ELEVEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM PROTEIN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I'M HERE TODAY IN MY INDIVIDUAL
CAPACITY AS A FORMER COLLEAGUE
AND FRIEND OF MISS PAULA THE
BRIEF TO SUPPORT HER
CONFIRMATION TO THE CALIFORNIA
GAMBLING CONTROL COMMISSION AND
DO ME A FAVOR I HAVE KNOWINGLY
DO ME FAVOR AND GIVE ME YOUR
NAME IF YOU COULD I'M SO SORRY-
I'M- I APOLOGIZE SOLUTION
MARSHALL. OF COURSE I HAVE NO.
WORRIES FOR ALL. WELL THANK YOU
MISS MARSHALL I'M SO SORRY.
YEAH WE WERE JUST HAVING A
CHUCKLE WE'RE JUST HAVING A
CHUCKLE- RESET GO FORWARD MISS
MARSHALL IT'S GOOD TO HEAR FROM
YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE KNOWN AS
LIBERTY FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS
BOTH PROFESSIONALLY AND
PERSONALLY. WE ARE BOTH OUR
CLASSMATES AND HASTINGS COLLEGE
OF THE LAW. JUST A BRIEF WHO
CURRENTLY SERVES AS CHAIR OF
THE COMMISSION ANYWAY CERTAINLY
NUMEROUS LEADERSHIP ROLES TO
OUR LEGAL AND PROFESSIONAL
CAREER IS EXCEPTIONALLY WELL
QUALIFIED FOR DISAPPOINTMENT. I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT HER
CONFIRMATION AND ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT WITNESS. MEDLINE.
TWENTY FIVE. NINE TWENTY FIVE
YOUR PHONE MAY BE I MEAN. I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JOHN TO I
HAVE BEEN A BRAND AND A LONG
TIME SUPPORTER OF MY- EDWARD G.
HE HAS BEEN. PROBABLY ONE OF
THE MORE- SUPPORTER FRIEND
UNDERGRAD- BOTH IN MY
PROFESSIONAL CAPACITY IN MY AND
MY PERSONAL CAPACITY. FIVE
KNOWN ED SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
SIX WHEN HE WAS WITH LOS
ANGELES CARMEN WHEN I WAS WORTH
BE LOCKED UNDER SHERIFF
DEPARTMENT. I WE WORK VERY IS
DIFFERENT TASK FORCES TOGETHER
WE WORKED UNDERCOVER TOGETHER
AND WE WORKED ON VARIOUS
DIFFERENT- LAW ENFORCEMENT
EFFORTS TOGETHER- I'VE KNOWN
HIM TO MAKE QUICK DECISIVE
DECISIONS WITH CAREFUL
CONSIDERATION OF ALL SITES- HE-
AS SHOWN AND DEMONSTRATED THAT
HE CAN BE. VERY ARE ORIENTED
TOWARDS JURISDICTION LIABILITY
ISSUES WHICH WOULD. WHICH WOULD
GREATLY ENHANCE HIS POSITION IN
THE FAMILY- IT HAS A GAMBLING
COMMISSIONER- ARE YOU CRY
STRONGLY SUPPORT HIS NOMINATION
AND- BOB HOPE TO SEE HIM. HE
BEING VERY SUCCESSFUL THE
TEACHER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER MODERATOR NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO FOR LONG LINES IN
QUEUE FOR SUPPORT OKAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH WILL BE BACK WITH
YOU IN A MOMENT OKAY WE'RE
GOING TO GO THROUGH THE SAME
PROCESS ODD TO HEAR FROM ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION. COMING BACK INTO
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE I
ACTUALLY SEE NO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION LOOKING AT ROOM ONE
TWELVE STILL NO INDIVIDUALS
HAVE ENTERED THAT ROOM SO MR
MODERATOR LET ME COME BACK TO
YOU. AGAIN. THANK YOU IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO STATE OPPOSITION
TO ANY OF THE- NOMINEES YOU MAY
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. HAVE BEEN ALLOWED A
MOMENT FOR RECLINES TO PLACE
THEMSELVES IN Q. THERE ARE NO
LINES AT THIS TIME. MISTER
ROGER RAIDER THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ASSISTANCE AND HELP TODAY WE SO
MUCH APPRECIATE. YOUR BEING
WITH US SO THANK YOU- I'M GONNA
I IS I ENTERTAIN A MOTION I'M
GOING TO ASK FOR SEPARATION OF
MOTIONS I'M JUST GOING TO GO
THROUGH EACH ONE- AS A COURTESY
THERE WAS A REQUEST FOR
SEPARATION SO LET ME START.
WITH THE CHAIR OF THE GAMBLING
CONTROL COMMISSION- MISS PAUL
IN THE BRIE AND ASK FOR A
MOTION FOR WITH SO MOVE THANK
YOU SENATOR ON MADAM SECRETARY
WE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GROWTH
HI. I FACE. HI THE AYE ATKINS
FIVE SEVEN FIVE FIVE. FIVE ZERO
THANK YOU AND CONGRATULATIONS
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU ALL I
WOULD ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR
MISS KATHLEEN GALGIANI. R. NINE
BUT LIKE THE PREDATOR GROCERY
DO THAT YEAH. THE THOUGHT HAS
MADE IT MY MISSION MADAM
SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. GROWTH HI REVISED ON
WATER HI MONGER I'D THERE'D HI
THERE I EIGHT FIVE. I HAVE BEEN
HI RIGHT FIVE FIVE ZERO
CONGRATULATIONS MISS COUNTY ANI
AND- I LET ME ASK FOR A MOTION
FOR MISTER ERIC HEINZ. HELLO I
THINK I HEARD SENATOR COM
LONGER I WILL ACCEPT THAT ONE
SENATOR LAYERED YOU'RENOT
OFFENDED I ASSUME NO. THANK YOU
THAT'S KAMLAGER MADE A MOTION
MADAM SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. OVER NO PROOF NO HOW
MARKER HI LONGER I THERE'D ALL
RIGHT I BATES ABSTAINED. ITSELF
THEN ATKINS FIVE CONFIDED. A
THREE ONE THAT- MOST ALSO
PASSES CONGRATULATIONS MISTER
HINES- I WOULD ACCEPT A MOTION
FOR MISTER EDWARD II. CENTER
GROVE HAS MOVED MADAM SECRETARY
WILL YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ROW HI I KAMLAGER I. HI THERE
HI HI EIGHT FIVE EIGHT I ATKINS
BY I THINK. ZERO FIVE ZERO OF
THAT IS APPROVED
CONGRATULATIONS TO MR YE AND TO
ALL OF YOU YOUR APPOINTMENT
YOUR APPOINTMENTS AND
CONFIRMATIONS WILL MOVE ON TO
THE SENATE FLOOR. LET ME
CONGRATULATE ALL OF YOU LET ME
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
TIME FOR THIS FAIRLY LONG
HEARING AT. WITH OUR
APPRECIATION FOR YOUR SERVICE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU BEST OF
LUCK TO YOU ALL. THEY ARE WITH
THAT LET'S SEE I WANNA- IT CAN
COULD THIS CONCLUDES ART
TODAY'S PUBLIC PORTION OF THE
AGENDA LET ME THANK ALL OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING. TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE FOR INSTRUCTIONS AGAIN
YOUR COMMENTS REALLY AND TRULY
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
THE OFFICIAL RECORD HEARING
RECORDS. SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COOPERATION THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON RULES WILL NOW
MOVE TO EXECUTIVE SESSION THANK
YOU.